Es ist soweit, wir sprechen über die 2. Liga der Männer im Rasenfunk. Endlich die Saison 2024-25. Jetzt erst hat sie offiziell begonnen mit dieser Ligatur. Wir wollen heute sprechen allgemein über die Liga und dann legen wir aber einen Schwerpunkt auf Schalke 04 und auf Darmstadt 98. Dazu habe ich zu Gast Matthias Kneifl und Dominik Slišković jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Und los geht's. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und schön, dass ich meine Gäste hier begrüßen darf und dass, obwohl einer von ihnen sich die perfekte Rasenfunk-Streak zerschießt. Es ist Dominik Slišković. Ihn kennt ihr unter anderem, weil er bei der Ed Broski Show arbeitet. Und Dominik, du warst 04-mal im Rasenfunk. Dir selbst ist es aufgefallen. Und weil du offenbar wirklich unbedingt hier sein willst, machst du das jetzt kaputt und kommst zum 05-mal. Schön, dass du hier bist, alter Mainzer.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung zu Mainz. Tatsächlich gar keine Connection. Ich habe da eher an die ZDF-Moderatorin von langer, langer Zeit her. Ich dachte, 05, dass wir das mal wieder rauskramen.
Ach, die Arme, dass das immer noch die Assoziation ist. Aber ja, ja, klar. Aber es ist trotzdem schön, dass du hier bist. Schön, dass du dir Zeit nimmst für den Rasenfunk. Wie ist es so gerade, Schalker zu sein?
Aufregend, wie so oft. Und mehr werde ich dir dann wahrscheinlich spätestens zu Weihnachten sagen können.
Ach so, ich dachte, heute noch in der Sendung hoffe ich. Also ich hoffe, dass ich schon mal wieder…
Ja, das natürlich auch. Ich werde dir ganz viel aus meinem Seelenleben als Schalker erzählen.
Okay, sehr gut. Ich werde versuchen, es nicht zu sehr zur Therapiestunde werden zu lassen, wobei das eine Herausforderung ist. Denn auch Matthias Kneifl hat seine Themen mit seinem Verein. Matthias, schön, dass wir miteinander hier sprechen. Ein bisschen schade, dass wir jetzt schon miteinander sprechen müssen, weil sich dein Verein so aufgedrängt hat. Aber schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, danke für die Einladung und die Ligen. Die Sonne weint eher im Moment, als sie scheint.
Ja, also wir werden einen Schwerpunkt auf diese beiden Vereine legen. Ihr habt damit schon gemerkt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn ihr die Ligatur auch schon in der Vergangenheit gehört habt, dass es neu ist. Bisher hatten wir hier immer drei Teams, die wir besprochen haben in der Zweitliga-Ligatur. Ich möchte das mal so probieren, weil mir an mir selbst aufgefallen ist in der letzten Saison, dass ich schon immer noch zwei, drei Fragen gehabt hätte und dann aber schon zum nächsten Verein gehen musste, damit die Sendung nicht zwei Stunden lang wird. Denn das muss ja alles auch noch gehört und produziert werden. Deswegen probieren wir es jetzt mal so und dann gebt ihr bitte sehr gerne Feedback, was ihr davon haltet. Was aber gleich bleiben soll, ist, dass wir jetzt gar nicht direkt mit euren Vereinen einsteigen, sondern ich möchte mal als jemand, der die zweite Liga irgendwie mitbekommen hat, aber gefühlt ist alles im Pleistocene geschehen. Also der Urlaub letzte Woche hat bei mir alles aus dem Stammhirn verbannt. Wir wollen mal allgemein auf die Liga blicken. Dominik, du darfst mal loslegen. Wenn ich mir diese Liga nach vier Spieltagen angucke, welche Überraschungen kann ich da deiner Meinung nach erkennen?
Wir sprechen ja später noch dezidiert über Darmstadt, aber ich finde es schon eine Überraschung, dass die so schnell in Schwierigkeiten kommen, dass sie so schnell auch die Trainerentlassungstaktik ziehen, was ich vielleicht auch aus persönlicher Sicht überraschend finde, ist, dass Preuß Münster– ich als alter Münsterländer habe da natürlich einen Blick drauf– dass Preuß Münster sich doch so tapfer schlägt. Das kommt jetzt komisch rüber, wenn man das 1 zu 4 gegen den HSV noch im Hinterkopf hat und auch dieses sehr, sehr brutale 0 zu 5 im Pokal gegen Stuttgart. Aber ich finde, davor gab es echt drei solide Auftritte, wo mehr drin gewesen wäre. Und auch gerade, wenn man schaut, wie dieser Verein mit dem Doppelaufstieg– also wir sind ja durchmarschiert von der Vierten in die Zweite Liga– mit einem Stadion, was ja halb abgerissen ist, wo quasi langfristig geplant wurde eigentlich, dass das Stadion neu gebaut wird oder umgebaut wird und man dann quasi sich Richtung Zweite Liga roppt. Und jetzt ist man plötzlich in der Zweiten Bundesliga und muss quasi so on the go schauen, dass man irgendwie Lücken schließt mit– ach, wir brauchen ja auch noch Rollstuhlplätze im Stadion und noch mehr VIP-Boxen, mehr Plätze für Pressevertreter und so weiter. Und dann auch schaut, dass man sich, wie ich finde, gar nicht so stark verstärkt hat auf dem Transfermarkt. Man hat ein wenig Zweitliga-Erfahrung reingeholt. Aber ich fand es zum Beispiel gerade auf der Torhüterposition selber erraschend, dass man mit der Nummer 2 aus der Vorsaison, Schenk, weitergeht, dass man ihn festverslichtet hat vom FC Bayern. Da ist ja mit Maxi Schulze-Nihos eine absolute Preußenlegende weggebrochen. Ein absoluter Führungsspieler mit seinen dann 35 Jahren am Ende. Und dann einen 21-Jährigen, der also das erste Mal wirklich Nummer 1 ist im Profibereich. Da auch so das Vertrauen auszusprechen, ist schon aller Ehre wert. Gerade eben, weil man bei Preußen weiß, es geht von Minute 1 bis zur letzten Minute am 34. Spieltag eigentlich nur um den Klassenhalt.
Sehr schöner, etwas unerwarteter Preußen-Exkurs an dieser Stelle. Wobei da natürlich Matthias nur leise in sich hineinlächeln kann. Also so ein Durchmarsch von der Regionalliga in die 2. Liga, das ist ja total lame. Die richtig coolen Vereine, die machen das genau mit demselben, schlechten Stadion und so weiter von der 3. Liga in die 1. Liga und sind damit dann auch heillos überfordert. So haben wir uns ja ein bisschen kennengelernt, Matthias.
Das stimmt, wobei damals ja die Ligen streng genommen tatsächlich aus der Regionalliga kamen. Zumindest waren sie ja Drittliga-Absteiger, sportlich gesehen. Dann scheiterte Kikos Offenbach am grünen Tisch und dann ging es hoch in die 1. und die haben sich dann tatsächlich seinerzeit auch einmal gehalten. Also es war dann schon die Verlängerung des Märchens, wenn man so will. Und das ging in diesem Sommer, wenn man so will, gar nicht. Also da ging es prompt wieder runter. Da hast du schon recht. Also die Märchenhaftigkeit der Ligen ist ein bisschen verloren gegangen.
Ja, aber ich wollte das gar nicht seitens der offenen Wunden stecken. Ich wollte eigentlich an diese glorreiche Aufstiegssituation erinnern. Also es ist ganz interessant für alle diejenigen, die die Tabelle nicht so wie wir vor Augen haben. Wir haben gerade über zwei Teams gesprochen. Also Darmstadt macht mir ja gleich noch ausführlicher. Die haben noch keinen Sieg. Die haben eine Tordifferenz von 2 zu 10. Und danach haben wir ein bisschen positiver über Preußen Münster gesprochen. Die haben noch keinen Sieg und haben eine Tordifferenz von 2 zu 8. Dominik hat es natürlich schon einsortiert. Man muss dieses 1 zu 4 gegen den HSV so ein bisschen einklammern. Aber wenn ich eben ans Ende der Tabelle blicke, da sehe ich da eben die drei Aufsteiger Regensburg, Ulm und Münster. Regensburg ist der einzige Verein von diesen dreien, der auch schon einen Sieg einfahren konnte. Dahinter noch Braunschweig. Die haben sich auch sehr hart beworben, hier in der Ligatur vorzukommen. Vier Niederlagen, drei zu 15 Tore. Also Eintracht Braunschweig werden wir uns auch mit befassen müssen. Matthias, wenn du auf die Tabelle blickst, ist es dann auch die Eintracht, die für dich eine Überraschung ist? Oder gibt es noch andere Vereine, die du interessant findest?
Ja, also natürlich ist die Saison noch sehr jung und vielleicht nicht mehr der größten Aussagekraft am Start. Aber ich würde tatsächlich eher den Blick nach oben wenden. Also jeder hat ja so ein bisschen oder viele zumindest gemutmaßt. Düsseldorf wird diesen Neckbreaker der dramatischen Relegation nicht so gut verkraften und ta-da, Trugschluss. Sie haben sich da ganz tapf vorausgekämpft, haben eine stabile Defensive, 5 zu 1 Tore, aber 10 Punkte. Also das heißt, sie haben sich an der Stelle einfach festgebissen. Sie haben auch natürlich starke Abgänge, wenn man so will, mit Jollis, aber dennoch auch wiederum wohl einiges gut gemacht im Sommer, um die Köpfe frei zu kriegen und nicht wie Darmstadt einen Misserfolg nachzuhängen, sondern gleich wieder anzugreifen. Am ersten Spieltag haben wir die Klinge gekreuzt gegen Düsseldorf, da haben sie 2-0 gewonnen. Dann haben sie dann im Endeffekt abgezockt, gespielt. Dann folgt schon Karlsruhe, auch für mich, gut zu heißen, was da geleistet wird an der Arbeit, weil die haben ja durchaus auch namhafte Spieler verloren in der jetzt abgelaufenen Transferperiode. Also Stindl und Gondorf haben aufgehört, als, denke ich mal, Erfahrenste Spieler. Matanovic wird sicherlich auch Dominik ein guter Begriff sein, ist nach Frankfurt zurückgegangen, weil er nur geliehen und Paul Nebel ist auch wieder zu seinem Stammverein zurück, nach zwei erfolgreichen Jahren meines Erachtens. Also es sind schon Namen, die da weggebrochen sind. Philipp Heise ist auch nach langer Zeit jetzt woanders hin entschwunden, aber befindet sich gleich wohl am Ende seiner Karriere. Was ich damit sagen will, mit der Aufzählung auch, es sind wirklich gestandene Profis nicht mehr am Start. Sie haben es geschafft, das gut wegzustecken und wenn ich das richtig aufgeschnappt habe, haben sie sogar in den ersten vier Saisonspielen immer dieselbe Elf auflaufen lassen. Also die neuen, die kamen, die dürfen sich so ein bisschen akklimatisieren und die, die schon da waren und vielleicht nicht so eine große Rolle gespielt haben in Summe, die dürfen sich jetzt beweisen und es geht auf. Und wenn ich die zwei Clubs exemplarisch nenne, dann zeichne die aus, dass sie auch jetzt schon länger auf demselben Trainer setzen. Also ich habe gestern mal kurz ein bisschen recherchiert, wenn man die Aufstiegstrainer rausrechnet. Dazu sehe ich jetzt noch einen Christian Titz bei Magdeburg oder auch Horst Schäffen bei Elbersberg, der der lange Diensteste Trainer der 2. Liga ist. Also nicht in der 2. Liga, aber eines Zwei-Liga-Vereins. Dann sind es schon Karlsruhe mit Eichner, dann Paderborn mit Krasniok und dann Düsseldorf mit Juhn. Also ansonsten nur Aufstiegstrainer. Und da, glaube ich, zeigt sich, dass sich Kontinuität durchaus auszeichnet. Also Heidenheim, du wirst natürlich aus erster Hand wissen, auch die haben einen langjährigen Trainer und die schaffen es, so Verluste wie Kleindienst und Beste zu kompensieren, weil sie irgendwie ein System haben, sich klug verstärken, nicht mit den größten Namen, aber die einfach in das System passen. Und vielleicht folgen ja Düsseldorf und Karlsruhe auch diesem Trend. Wir setzen auf bewährtes Personal auf der Trainerbank und das zahlt sich aus. Wie gesagt, für den Spieltag noch keine Aussagekraft, aber fürs Erste wirkt es so.
Ja, interessante Gedanken. Dahinter haben wir dann Föhrt, Magdeburg, Paderborn. Hättet ihr beide erwartet, dass der 1. FC Köln nach vier Spielen mit zwei Siegen, einem Unentschieden, einer Niederlage und einem sensationellen Torverhältnis, natürlich auch rausgeschossen im letzten Spiel vor der Länderspielpause, von 11. zu 5. steht? Also, ging das nur mir so oder dir auch, Dominik, dass man mit dem ganzen Drumherum, Transfersperre und so weiter, die Sorgen waren ja durchaus groß, die man sich da machen konnte rund um den FC. Ich hätte es nicht erwartet. Wie geht es dir damit?
Ja, wobei man ja auch sagen muss, der FC ist ja Marktwert-Tabellenführer der 2. Bundesliga. Und du hast die Transfersperre angesprochen. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man auch schauen, wie viele Leistungsträger aus der vergangenen Saison sich dann doch zum Verein bekannt haben. Sei es jetzt der Jan Jubečić, auch wenn da ja lange bis zum Schluss noch gemunkelt wurde, Jürgen Begeta bleibt da, wie auch immer. Deniz Husein Basit ist geblieben, also zwei sehr spielstarke Spieler im Mittelfeld. Und ich glaube, mich hat es jetzt nicht so überrascht, dass sie jetzt nicht komplett mit vier Niederlagen reingestartet sind. Ich hatte mir eher ein bisschen Sorgen gemacht, ob sie mit dem neuen Trainer auch wirklich sofort warm werden. Aber das scheint jetzt auch vermehrt der Fall zu sein. Von daher glaube ich, man kann mit dem FC auf jeden Fall oben mitrechnen, je länger die Saison auch läuft. Weil sie halt auch einfach Erfahrungen haben, die sich dann vielleicht nach hinten raus auszahlen könnte. Das Einzige, was ich so ein bisschen unterm Strich als Schwachstelle des FC sehe, ist der Sturm. Weil ich glaube, da hätten sie sich wirklich, hätten sie die Transfersperre nicht gehabt, nochmal anders und besser aufstellen können. Also ich traue jetzt einem Tim Lämpere oder einem Steffen Tigges nicht irgendwie 10-plus Tore zu. Und ich glaube, das könnte dann doch am Ende der Saison irgendwie den Ausschlag geben. Gerade weil die 2. Liga jetzt in den vergangenen Jahren ja immer so der Fall war, dass auf einmal ein Team, was zu dieser Saison beginnt, gar nicht so oben mitgerechnet wurde, dann eine starke Rückrunde erwischt. Auch weil ein, zwei Spieler sich in den Vordergrund spielen oder schießen. Und da sehe ich eben für den FC dann das Potenzial, dass da die Körner am Ende der Saison fehlen könnten im Sturm.
Ja, interessante Gedanken.
Genau, das mag durchaus stimmen. Ich glaube, bei vorne haben sie tatsächlich ein gewisses Loch, das ihnen vielleicht auf die Füße fallen könnte. Grundsätzlich ist es bei Köln ja aber genauso. Das Umfeld und das Publikum kann man schnell anzünden. Und vielleicht ist jetzt durch die Transferperiode auch so ein bisschen was noch mal enger zusammengeknüpft worden. Und wenn sie jetzt erfolgreich spielen, dann kommt eins zum anderen. Sie haben immer noch ein relativ junges Team und müssen jetzt zwangsläufig auf die eigenen Reserven sozusagen setzen. Und haben ja auch durchaus mit Tiedemann oder Finkrefe oder jetzt mit dem Julian Pauli oder Damian Downs auch Leute, die aus dem 2. Lig kommen. Und es ist ja dann immer super, wenn so was irgendwie aufzugehen scheint. Das kann man dann wirklich noch mal sagen, das sind unsere Jungs, die wurden nicht gekauft. Die sind aus dem eigenen Unterbau nach oben gezogen worden und kreieren dann was. Also ich kann mich da noch sehr gut an den VfB Stuttgart von damals, von vor 20 Jahren erinnern, als die jungen Wilden waren. Das war auch so aus der Not geboren, dass plötzlich die Jungs aus der 2. Mannschaft hochziehen mussten von Andi Hinkel über Chleb und Korani und Amanatidis und Tiffert und Co. Die haben es dann bewiesen, dass sie es können. Das hat mit damals, weil ich das aus nächster Nähe auch erleben konnte, hat das Publikum schon sehr begeistert. Also in Stuttgart war wirklich wie eine Neugeburt sozusagen des Vereins damals fast vonstatten gegangen. Wer weiß, vielleicht kann Köln eine ähnliche Geschichte erzählen in der 2. Liga, dass sich das tatsächlich trägt.
Wobei ich sagen muss, Schalke hat jetzt kürzlich gegen Köln gespielt und verloren. Mit Hilfe der DFL und der Schiedsrichter und des Kölner Kellers. So viel Zeit muss sein. Aber ich muss sagen, spielerisch war Köln jetzt nicht unbedingt 3-1 überlegen, so wie es das Endergebnis wieder gespiegelt hat. Deswegen auch vorhin meine Anmerkungen Richtung Gerhard Struber. Ich glaube, da ist noch viel Entwicklungspotenzial in dieser Mannschaft, auch weil es eben doch viele junge Spieler sind. Aber nach dem Spiel bin ich aus der Felddienst Arena rausgegangen und habe gedacht, ok, ja, Marktwert-Tabellenführer und ich würde den FC weiterhin irgendwie in der Top 6 sehen am Ende der Saison. Aber da finde ich spielerisch andere Teams ansprechender nach vier Spieltagen in der 2. Liga. Also da muss, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen Wasser den Reihen runterlaufen und noch ein paar Fans angezündet werden in Milnaßdorf, damit dann aus dieser Mannschaft wirklich die jungen, wilden 2.0 werden.
Gut, das ist ja eh klar. Bevor wir jetzt dann zu euren Vereinen kommen, aber würde ich sagen, noch einmal ganz kurz Pro und Contra Dopingsperre Vusković. Nee, war ein Witz, können wir jetzt natürlich nicht machen. Ich wollte nur eure Gesichter sehen, dass ich das unangekündigt mache. Also das ist ein Riesenthema. Es wäre eigentlich auch ein Thema für ein Tribüngengespräch. Aber ob ich das hinkriege, liebe Leute, das weiß ich nicht. Es gibt schon sehr, sehr gute Podcasts dazu. Ich habe unter anderem Mia Güte hat im Themenfrühstück bei Freunde da auch einmal sehr kompetent das noch mal zusammengefasst. Ich wollte nur diesen Namen, der muss fallen, weil das darf nicht so komplett unter dem Radar laufen. Die Dopingsperre wurde jetzt bestätigt. Der HSV hat sich insofern hinter den Spieler gestellt, dass man ihm jetzt eine andere Funktion gibt. Und er dann ab 2026, wenn die Sperre wieder abgelaufen sein wird, dass man ihn dann wieder integrieren möchte in den Profikader. Ob das klappt und wie das alles zustande kam, dass diesem jungen Spieler, der sich vielleicht etwas zu schulden hat, kommen lassen. Aber man ist weit davon entfernt zu sagen, sicherlich war es so. Denn dafür sind die Zweifel einfach zu groß. Das ist ein irres Thema. Ich wollte es kurz hier haben.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein irres Thema. Ich glaube, ich springe mal kurz drauf. Man sieht ja auch in anderen Sportarten, Janik Sinner hat ja auch quasi jetzt Anfang des Jahres ein Doping-Vergehen und es wurde dann so aufgeklärt, dass es wohl an einer Verletzung, so einem Physio lag, der dann einen Spray oder sonst was benutzt hat, um diese Wunde sozusagen zu versorgen, dann Sinner wohl behandelt hat. Und daraufhin Sinner plötzlich positiv getestet wird. Und meines Erachtens, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, zweimal. Also wie lange hat der Junge den Mann über Wochen im Werk mit diesem Ding massiert? Ist schon schwierig und das kam irgendwie jetzt zwar mit einem verlorenen Turniersieg, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen glimpflich für ihn rum, diese Geschichte. Also sprich, hier haben wir einen Weltklasse-Spieler im Tennis, der keine Ahnung schuldig ist oder auch nicht. Aber zumindest wurde das relativ enchangélo abgegügelt. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir einen noch relativ jungen Fußballer, der jetzt quasi ein Berufsverbot hat. Also das hat mich auch gewundert, das ist jetzt auch vier Jahre. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das auch im Raum stand oder ob es einfach verlängert wurde. Sprich, man hat die gesamte mögliche Sperrzeit ausgeschöpft. Aber das fand ich jetzt auch, ohne es zu genau zu kennen, überraschend.
Ja, also Yannick Sinner ist eben noch mal ein ganz eigenes Thema. Ich habe in einem anderen Podcast gehört, wo noch gelobt wurde, wie er es geschafft hat, diese Dropping-schwarze Wolke über seinen Kopf zu vertreiben und die US Open zu gewinnen. Ja, da gratuliere ich auch ganz herzlich zu. Wirklich bemerkenswert. Und gleichzeitig, er hatte die Mittel, auch die finanziellen Mittel, juristisch das durchzufächten. Es gibt jetzt gleichzeitig eine Tennisspielerin, der Namen ich leider gerade nicht parat habe, die in einem ganz ähnlich gelagerten Fall ist und die hat aber eben genau diese Mittel nicht. Das kommt eben auch noch mit dazu. Aber gut, ich wollte es nur kurz erwähnen. Es wird sicherlich auch noch journalistisch aufgearbeitet werden. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich das im Rasenfunk machen kann. Neulich schon mal erste Skizzen dazu gemacht und da war das eigentlich eine Podcast-Staffel und ist eigentlich von einem kaum zu leisten. Lasst uns auf eure Vereine blicken. Und ich würde fast sagen, Matthias, ich hoffe für Dominik, ist es okay, dass wir mit Darmstadt 98 beginnen. Darmstadt ist abgestiegen in die 2. Liga und jetzt haben wir 4 Spiele gespielt und Darmstadt ist vorletzter. Okay, das kann passieren. Darmstadt hat aber auch keinen Trainer mehr. Das musst du uns gleich erzählen, wie es dazu kommen konnte. Und heute wurde auch noch bekannt, dass zwei wesentliche Spieler jetzt schon im Grunde der Saison aus– habe ich das richtig gelesen?
Das stimmt, ja. Also zum einen Matze Bader, Rechtsverteidiger oder Schiedenspieler, je nachdem, welches System gespielt wird, hatte ich auf meinem Zettel für einen, der letzte Saison in der Bundesliga hätte auf sich aufmerksam machen können. Da war es leider nicht der Fall, aber er kann schon was. Und Kreuzbandriss und Außenminiskussriss und Paul Will. So der Strategie von hinten raus sollte er wohl werden auf der 6. Position. Ebenfalls Kreuzbandriss und Innenminiskussriss. Also ich glaube, Paul Will verletzt im Testspiel gegen Mainz und Matze Bader im Training. Und das ist schon wirklich dramatisch. Also das letzte Mal, als ich bei dir zu Gast war, da wurde am selben Tag verkündet, dass Clemens Riedl einen Knöchelbruch hat. Und jetzt nehmen wir vier Stunden auf, nachdem diese Nachricht bei mir ins Smartphone flattert. Also das ist schon wirklich kein leichter Start jetzt für Kohfeldt, weil ich glaube, Will war wirklich jemand, auf den man gesetzt hat, schon unter Lieberknecht. Für mich der ganz klare Stratege von hinten raus in einer Kombination mit Clevis, der eher der etwas körperliche Sechser ist. Und nun denn, die Option bricht weg. Aber um das Ganze noch mal ein bisschen aufzudröseln, Dominik hatte vorhin gemeint, Trainerentlassung. Im Endeffekt wird es jetzt so dargestellt, dass Thorsten Lieberknecht tatsächlich von sich aus die Konsequenz gezogen hat. Das Arbeitsverhältnis zu beenden gleichwohl wird wohl weiterhin Gehalt gezahlt. Also war ich jetzt auch etwas überrascht, aber das hieß es im Umfeld der Willkommens-PK für Kohfeldt, dass die Ligen ihn bezahlen. Wie lange auch immer. Also ich hätte gedacht, wenn jemand seinen Verlag kündigt, dann ist es erstmal im Endeffekt sein Pech. Abfindungen muss man sich wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie einigen. Aber Stand jetzt zahlt man zwei Trainer und der Co-Trainer von Thorsten Lieberknecht, Obetajow wurde auch entlassen. Sprich, man hat jetzt im Endeffekt gerade zwei Cheftrainer und drei Co-Trainer auf der Payroll und da sind noch keine Torwart-Trainer und andere Staff dabei. Nun denn. Also, was soll ich sagen. Sehr verquäre Situationen. Thorsten Lieberknecht konnte ich noch vor Saisonstart sprechen, weil ich für das Stadion-Magazin ihn zum dritten Mal vor der Saison interviewen durfte. Und ich war gespannt, welchen Trainer ich vorfinde bei dem Gespräch. Und er war sehr aufgeräumt. Also, er war wirklich auch voller Vorfreude auf die neue Saison. Er hat ja letzte Saison noch gegen Ende hin für Schlagzeilen gesorgt, als er gesagt hat, er konnte die Bundesliga nie genießen. Das glaubt man ihm aufs Erste. Aber das so dann auch auszusprechen, war schon ein Zeichen, was so eine Saison mit einem Trainer und auch Menschen macht. Dennoch wirkte er vor der Saison auf mich sehr zuversichtlich. Es war ja wie quasi neues Spielerpersonal, das ihm auch zugekommen ist. Und da glaubt er schon, was vorzufinden, aus dem er wieder was kreieren kann. Und diese Vorfreude, die war wohl nach wenigen Wochen verpufft. Und da gab es zwei Statements, die, glaube ich, ganz gut durchblicken lassen. Was hier in den wenigen Tagen wohl dann auch passiert ist, weil er hatte noch vor dem Spiel in Elbersberg das 0 zu 4 ausging. Sprich deutlich verloren. Man hätte auch höher verlieren können. Da hatte er in der Vor-PK gesagt, sie spüren, dass da eine Entwicklung enorm zugenommen hat. Also sprich, da findet was zusammen. Das Spiel davor war gegen Köln. Bestes Spiel bislang in der Saison. Schmeichelhaft, dass es nur 1 zu 1 aus Nürnbergersicht ausgegangen ist. Oder dass es überhaupt 1 zu 1 ausgegangen ist. Die Ligen hätten da den Sack diverse Male zumachen können, haben spielerisch überzeugt, aber leider den Dreier liegen lassen. Und ich glaube, da hat dann Lieberknecht was erkannt, was ihm taugt und was aufgehen könnte. Und er hatte damals in dem Vorgespräch auch zu mir gesagt, er ist eigentlich gar nicht so der Trainer, der jetzt eine Mannschaft wild durcheinanderwürfelt. Er ist eigentlich jemand, der durchaus auf ein Korsett setzt und gar nicht so viel umstellen mag. Das war in der Bundesliga anders. Verletzungsbedingten zum meisten.
Jetzt wissen wir, was er ohne die Verletzungen gemacht hätte.
Ja, aber von diesem, wir spüren hier, ist eine Entwicklung, die einen Pfad auf, hin zu nach dem Elbersberg-Spiel, sprich zwei Tage oder ein Tag später, ja nur, oder zwei. Ich fühle mich komplett von meiner Mannschaft im Stich gelassen. Das ist schon ein wirklich starker Tobak. Also hier jemand, der vor dem Spiel glaubt, hier greift was und dann nach dem Spiel merkt, hier habe ich gerade Schiffbruch erlitten. Und das war wohl für ihn tatsächlich dann das, was das Fass zum Überlaufen gebracht hat, weil im Endeffekt gab es die letzten 15 Monate ja nur Nackenschläge. Es hat sich nie ein Momentum entwickelt. Man kam nie so wirklich aus dem Quark. Ja, das war schon, glaube ich, auch was psychisch mit einem und mental viel macht, weil er musste ja immer wieder Aufbauarbeit leisten und es hat nicht gefruchtet. Also wahrscheinlich hat es dies auch irgendwann abgenutzt.
Aber wie hast du denn das Darmstädter Umfeld seit Saisonbeginn wahrgenommen? Also hast du das Gefühl gehabt, dass es vielleicht auch an Rückendeckung für Lieberknecht gefehlt hat als Abstiegstrainer? Und wir gehen jetzt aber frischen und neuen Mutes rein, dass sich das dann eben auch relativ schnell abgezeichnet hat bei ihm oder in der Mannschaft. Okay, so richtig hinter ihm stehen sie nicht, aber er hat uns halt in die Bundesliga hochgebracht und wir sind zusammen runtergegangen. Jetzt versuchen wir es nochmal.
Ja, also es war fast ein bisschen paradox, weil nach dem Spiel gegen Elbersberg, da waren auch die Ultras ein bisschen auf dem Zaun und haben die Mannschaft so ein bisschen kritisiert. Aber es gab keine wirklichen Lieberknecht-Rausrufe oder sowas. Und deshalb war das lange ruhig. Also man hat den Trainer nie wirklich angezählt. Das war was, was ihm auch was bedeutet hat, hatte er mir damals auch gesagt. Es gab aber gleichwohl in den sozialen Medien sehr viel Unmut, weil man gemerkt hat, jetzt geht diese Scheiße schon wieder los. Das ist tatsächlich was, was viele umgetrieben hat. Und als dann die Trennung ausgesprochen war, da gab es ein, ja wie soll ich sagen, ein Übermaß an Liebe, das über Torsten Lieberknecht ausgeschüttet wurde. Also es zeigt, dass er als Mensch, und er hat sich ja komplett mit Haut und Harn dem Verein glaubhaft verschrieben und dem Umfeld und er wusste auch immer um die Wichtigkeit der Beziehung zwischen Umfeld, Mannschaft und Trainerteam, dass das honoriert wurde, aber gleichwohl wurden schon viele nervös, zumindest in den sozialen Medien, die gesagt haben, also jetzt nochmal so eine annähernde Saison wie letztes Jahr, das geht halt nicht. Also wir müssen auch irgendwann mal die Bremse reinhauen. Und deshalb, ja, war die Situation sicherlich nicht ruhig, aber sie war nicht im Stadion vernehmbar, dass die Leute auf die Barrikaden gegangen sind. Nach Elbersberg finde ich klar, dass man da auch den Support als Ultra einstellt und dann auch nach dem Spiel zu verstehen gibt. Also von dem Auftritt halten wir mal gar nichts, aber es wurde nicht Lieberknecht rausgedeutet. Ja, das vielleicht zu dem Thema.
Also das ergibt ja alles für sich, nur wenn man spekuliert sind. Also weil, wenn man spekuliert, dann kann man sagen, es gibt hier eine Missstimmung, die Darmstadt mitgenommen hat. Interessanterweise hat man die sogar schon in die 1. Liga mitgenommen, aber da würde ich sagen, war es jetzt noch kein wirkliches Thema. Aber wie dann diese 1. Liga-Saison verlaufen ist, mit auch dem Clinch, den es gab, das war das Augsburg-Spiel, glaube ich, das 0 zu 6. Wo es zu Hause, wo es dann auch innerhalb der Fans, wir haben das alles im Rasenfunk hier schon aufgearbeitet, letzte Saison, deswegen reichen, glaube ich, die Stichworte. Also da hat man ganz offensichtlich etwas mitgenommen in die neue Saison. Wo es jetzt aber bei mir quasi aufhört, ist, also daran kann ich mir erklären, warum man auf der einen Seite diesen Trainer so toll findet und auf der anderen Seite aber dann doch vielleicht sogar erleichtert ist, dass es vorbei ist, weil man eben Angst hat, dass hier etwas wirklich noch schlimmer vor die Hunde geht. Aber was ich eben wirklich nur mit Spekulation füllen kann, da fühle ich mich jetzt wie künstliche Intelligenz, da bin ich Jetschi-Bit hier an der Stelle. Ich muss quasi mir selbst die Wahrheit herbeifabulieren, ist eben genau dieser Umsprung, den du erklärt hast. Direkt nach dem Elbersberg-Spiel bis hin zu zwei Tage später eine vermeintlich einvernehmliche Trennung, die aber auch gar nicht einvernehmlich aussieht. Geht das nur hier so oder hast du auch diese Lücken quasi, diese Logik?
Ja, also, um es nochmal aufzudröseln, Elbersberg, Samstag nach dem Spiel, PK, wo jeder, der es verfolgt hat oder nochmal nachgeschaut hat, gesehen hat, hier ist jemand doch durchaus ein bisschen am Ende mit seinen Dateien und ist auch ratlos und persönlich getroffen. Und dann, als quasi 24 Stunden später über die Gazetten herauskam, ja, Lieberknecht und die Ligen trennen sich. Da wurde so vermeldet, dass Lieberknecht von sich aus den Rücktritt angeboten hat. Und dann gab es auch von Vereinsseite Stimmen, ja, wenn jemand nicht mehr hundertprozentig mit voller Tatkraft und Überzeugung dahinter steht, warum soll man dann weitermachen? Ich glaube, dass er natürlich intern auch schon hinterfragt wurde, mehr als hinterfragt wurde. Er hätte auch die erste Liga, glaube ich, nicht durchgestanden, wenn er nicht Torsten Lieberknecht gewesen wäre. Also, wenn wir jetzt einer der anderen Trainer, die wir mal hatten, Dimi Kramoces oder Markus Anfang, wenn er die gewesen wäre, dann wären die zur ersten Liga, glaube ich, nicht länger Trainer gewesen. Aber da er ja auch Verdienste hatte, also er hat die Ligien nach seiner Ankunft zuerst auf Platz 4 geführt, dann auf Platz 2, hat mit unterschiedlichen Systemen gearbeitet, hat gezeigt, dass er mit Spielern so umgehen kann, dass er ein System findet, das zur Mannschaft passt und das unterschied sich durchaus zwischen erster Zwo-Liga-Spielzeit und dann Aufstiegssaison. Und man hat schon gesehen, er versteht es, eine Mannschaft auch weiterzubringen und zu stabilisieren vor allem. Und dass dann die erste Liga so Schiffbruch erlitt, da spielen viele Faktoren mit rein, aber er hat es irgendwie plötzlich verloren. Das Fingerspitzengefühl. Also das hat mich selber überrascht, dass man es über so lange Zeit hinweg nicht schafft, ein System zu implementieren, das irgendwie funktioniert. Also es waren mal Lichtblicke, aber die waren mit dem nächsten Spiel schon wieder vom Sockel gestoßen. Und man hat einfach Nachsicht gehabt mit Lieberknecht, weil man wusste um seine Verdienste. Und man hat ihm auch vorzeitig ja seinen Vertrag verlängert, was auch sehr viel Unmut im Umfeld herbeigeführt hat, weil man sich dachte, wieso soll man jetzt ohne, dass was passiert ist, schon zwei Jahre verlängern, obwohl der Vertrag sogar noch zwei Jahre gelaufen wäre. Also merkwürdig. Und da sind die Linien ja auch ein gebranntes Kind mit Torsten Frings, der einen Vertrag verlängert bekommt und dann drei Jahre aussitzt, ohne noch einen Vertrag einzufinden. Also es haben viele nicht verstanden.
Man kämpft das ja, mehrere Trainer gleichzeitig zu bezahlen, wenigstens stundenlang.
Ja, also nach der Saison ist auch der Präsident Rüdiger Fritsch vor die Kamera getreten und hat sehr lange ausgebreitet, wie denn die Lehren waren, die man eine Woche nach Saisonende beim Zusammensitzen gefunden hat. Und da ging es um allgemeine Themen, aber auch um sportliche Themen. Und ja, also wie gesagt, wäre Torsten Lieberknecht nicht Torsten Lieberknecht gewesen, würde ich sogar vermuten, wäre der dann Trainer auch nicht so sehr fest im Sattel gesessen. Aber die Geschichte war leider Gottes doch auserzählt. Also er hat einfach nicht mehr den Zugriff gekriegt, um das Team so hinzubiemen, dass es wieder funktioniert.
Okay, das ist jetzt besser nachvollziehbar für mich. Bleibt die eine Frage, warum Florian Kohfeldt?
Gute Frage. Nächste Frage. Nein, also hat uns, glaube ich, alle überrascht. Es wurden ja zwei Namen konkret genannt, unter anderem auf kicker.de, neben Florian Kohfeldt, auch Thomas Letsch. Den hatte ich tatsächlich sogar ein bisschen als meinen Lieblingsfavoriten ausgedeutet, schon bevor es in der Verlosung war. Aber so eng in der Verlosung war er wohl doch nicht. Also man hat sich relativ schnell auf Florian Kohfeldt eingeschossen. Und wenn ich regelkapituliere, was mir Lieberknecht vor der Saison noch so in Block diktiert hat, was er gerne spielen will. Und wenn ich jetzt höre, was Kohfeldt spielen will, dann finde ich es nicht ganz deckungsgleich, weil er sagte jetzt, Lieberknecht zum Beispiel, er will lieber mehr Umschaltspiel spielen. Also als er kam zu den Lilien, war es eine Ballbesitzmannschaft, dementsprechend auch mit durchaus Tempodefiziten, was sich bis zur Bundesliga durchgezogen hat. Und er wollte mehr Tempo, er wollte hohes Pressing, er wollte auch mal stressigere Phasen für den Gegner, abwechselnd mit ruhigeren Phasen. Also er wollte einfach vielleicht ein bisschen turbulenteren Fußball spielen. Und dann kommt jemand wie Kohfeldt, der sagt, er will mutigen Fußball spielen, er will zielgerichtet und dominanten Beibesitzfußball spielen. Und immer auf der Suche nach Tempoaktionen. Okay, Tempo hier wie dort, aber Beibesitzfußball versus Umschaltspiel, das ist schon was, was mich ein bisschen krübeln lässt. Und vor allem die Aussage, er will mutigen Fußball spielen. Ich glaube, alles, was die Ligen jetzt bräuchten, wäre eher eine Stabilität. Aber mutigen Fußball kann auch schwierig sein.
Ich wäre ohnehin immer vorsichtig für den Trainer sagen, sie wollen mutigen Fußball spielen, weil genau den Satz hat mir Demi Gramozes zu Schalker-Zeiten in meinem damaligen Blog diktiert, mutigen und aktiven Fußball. So, wie ich ihm dann gesagt habe, aber will das nicht jeder Trainer spielen lassen? Und er dann etwas verschnupft reagiert hat, aber das nur so am Rande. Also ich finde auch, das passt so ein bisschen zu dem Bild, was man von Florian Kohfeldt hat. Also eine sehr grobe Idee von Fußball mit vielen Schlagwörtern, wo man dann eben doch relativ schnell sieht, dass es eben an Tiefe fehlt. Ich weiß nicht, ob in seinem Taktikverständnis, in seiner Vor- und Nachbereitung, aber allein schon, dass er beim Verein wie Kass Olpen, der ja ein sehr ruhiges Umfeld ist, aber mit sehr guten Voraussetzungen eigentlich, also sowohl vom Aufbau des Vereins als auch von den Trainingsbedingungen her, das Ding da so an die Wand fährt, so ohne Glanz und Glorie untergeht, hat mich eigentlich eher zu dem Ergebnis kommen lassen, Florian Kohfeldt werden wir höchstens noch in der 3. Liga sehen bei Vereinen wie Alemannia Aachen, Rot-Weiß Essen, Dynamo Dresden. Florian Kohfeldt, Ex-Champions-League-Trainer, also großer Name, schmückt sich mit großem Namen. Das er jetzt doch bei Darmstadt, die ich ja doch auch als eher ruhigeres Umfeld wahrnehme, wo man eigentlich gut arbeiten kann, die in der Vergangenheit eigentlich immer auch gezeigt haben. Wenn man jemanden hat mit Idee, dann protegiert man den auch und dann kommen auch Ergebnisse bei rum, dass man so jemanden vorzieht, gerade wenn man jemanden wie Thomas Sledge auf dem Markt hat, den ich als durchaus fähigeren Trainer ansehe. Einfach weil ich mit ihm ein wenig über Fußball reden konnte, mit Thomas Sledge, und da kommt wirklich viel durch und viel rüber. Und auch einfach als Persönlichkeit, also ein ganz anderes Auftreten, ganz andere Verkauf, wenn man nach außen hat. Bin ich mal gespannt, ob und wie lange das gut gehen kann.
Also da noch ein paar Gedanken dazu. Mutiger Fußball ist vielleicht auch nur eine Schifffreffel für was weiß ich was, aber es darf auf keinen Fall naiv sein. Also wenn er glaubt, wir können hier irgendwas spielerisch lösen, wäre ich vorsichtig, ob das funktioniert.
Das ist aber eine harte Aussage. Also ich verstehe, was du meinst.
Genau, also wenn man auch jetzt seine vergangenen Vereine sieht, Werder wurde ihm ja auch wohl zum Verhängnis, dass er eine ziemliche Verletzungssäuche am Start hatte in der Abstiegssaison. Ich meine, er wurde einen Spieltag vor dem Abstieg entlassen, da lagen sie noch auf dem Relikationsplatz, also de facto war er mit der Abstiegs-Trainer. Aber jetzt fängt es bei Nielsen auch an. Die letzte Saison war ja auch schon verletzungsgeplagt, also mal gucken, was das wird. Viele sollten sich nicht verletzen. Nehmen wir da mal mit, Wolfsburg war ja wohl so, dass er auch ein Team vorgefunden hat, das nicht so richtig funktionierte, wenn man die Aussagen so retrospektiv deuten darf. Bei Nielsen hat sich noch kein Team gefunden. Deshalb bin ich auch mal gespannt, ob das Team dann funktionieren wird oder nicht. In Kasper Olpen hast du ja gesagt, da wurde ihm ja auch quasi nachgesagt, er hätte die Mannschaft in den Abstieg gerissen. Meines Wissens gibt es in Belgien eine Abstiegsrunde, an der er nicht mehr teilgenommen hat. Aber gleichwohl hat er die Mannschaft nicht aus der Abstiegsrunde rausgehalten. Es waren vier Teams, die an der Abstiegsrunde teilnehmen. Die wurden dann Olpen zum Verhängnis. Ich habe mal geguckt– Olpen ist mir ein Begriff klar– aber noch mal ein bisschen nachgeschlagen. Die haben seit 2016 erste Liga gespielt. Und jetzt, 2024 eben, abgestiegen, waren aber nie besser als Zwölfter. Es war eine Mannschaft, die per se immer gegen den Abstieg gespielt hat, waren aber unter Kohfeldt doch deutlich hinter dem Strich. Also fünf Punkte und 22 Tore hinter dem nicht abstiegsrunden Platz. Und er hatte auch durchaus ein paar alte Namen, die man aus Deutschland kennt. Victor Palsson kennen wir beide. Dominik hat da letztes Jahr gespielt. Ein Alfred Finn-Bogason und auch ein Kevin Möhwald. Also das sind durchaus Namen, die wir in Deutschland kennen, aber hat die Mannschaft nicht stabilisiert. Mal gucken, dass er jetzt in Darmstadt gelandet ist. Liegt vielleicht mit an diesen Punkten, die du genannt hast. Also Darmstadt ist ein ruhiges Umfeld. Das Präsidium ist auch gebetsmühlenartig, darum bemüht, den Deckel darauf zu halten. Und ein ruhiger Fritsch stellt sich hin und sagt, jetzt schauen wir nicht mehr nach hinten, das tut ihm für eigentlich gut, wir schauen nur noch nach vorne. Und das war auch so medial mit dem Thema, von Anfang an scheiße war es, jetzt wird aber nach vorne geguckt und dann muss man aber auch liefern. Und das wird wirklich spannend, ob man liefert. Ich meine, Kohfeldt hat auch bei seiner Vorstellung gesagt, er arbeitet gerne in einem Verein, der einer Stadt sehr viel bedeutet und danach hat er sich gesehnt. Das findet in Darmstadt. Hier hat er auch, wie gesagt, eine Rückendeckung vom Präsidium. Das hat auch quasi Fritsch noch mal unterstrichen. Wenn es 15 Monate so läuft, wie es lief und der Trainer dennoch nicht entlassen wird, dann heißt das schon was. Also er hat die Rückendeckung. Das war jetzt schon fast wieder kein Freifahrtschein, aber zumindest ein großer Vertrauensvorschuss, der ihm zugutekommt und vielleicht noch als Abbinder zu meinem Monolog. Lieberknecht und Kohfeldt haben denselben Berater. Vielleicht weiß also der Berater Mark Kosyke auch hier. Florian, du wurdest angerufen, guter Verein. Thorsten wurde hier nicht entlassen. Mit ihm durch Dick und Dücken gegangen. Das ist ein Umfeld, das dir behagt. Weder ein farbloses in Hochkommar Wolfsburg, noch ein No Name Open, noch ein was weiß ich was. Hier kannst du in Ruhe was aufbauen. Wir sind gespannt.
Das wäre gerne der Konterpunkt, den ich gemacht hätte. Bei der Kritik, die auch ich an Florian Kohfeldt üben könnte, muss man sagen, dieser Aspekt könnte tatsächlich sehr gut passen. Ein Trainer, der gut in der Darstellung nach außen ist. Kritiker mögen sagen, besser als die eigentliche Darstellung vor dem Team. Aber das gucken wir uns jetzt mal in Ruhe an. Aber der auch in der Lage ist, Dinge ins Positive zu drehen. Und auch diese Positivität nicht nur auszustrahlen, sondern ich glaube, der lebt das auch tatsächlich. Zumindest nehme ich ihm das ab. Und das wiederum kann ein Umfeld mitreißen. Und da gibt es viele Vereine, wo ich sage, ja gut, ist jetzt nicht so der Faktor. Bei Darmstadt allerdings würde ich sagen, kann das schon eine Rolle spielen. Und ich glaube, dahingehend kann das schon auch sehr gut passen.
Ja, also gleichwohl. Ich hatte es vorhin angedeutet, Lieberknecht wurde sehr, sehr bedauert im Umfeld, dass er geht und er hat sich auch emotional verabschiedet. Es ist auch eine Qualität, dass ein Trainer sowohl bei Braunschweig wie auch bei Darmstadt authentisch ankam und auch genauso trainreich verabschiedet wurde. Also an der Stelle nochmal Chapeau an das, was er hier auch über den Verein und den Spieltag hinaus geleistet hat. Und ich glaube, man muss jetzt Kohfeldt einfach auch zugestehen, dass er ein bisschen Zeit braucht, um Ergebnisse zu liefern. Und ich glaube, er weiß schon, gleichwohl, wenn er es negiert hat, dass hier für ihn viel auf dem Spiel steht. Also wenn er es jetzt ebenfalls wieder zum Misserfolg führt oder eben nicht aus der Abstiegszone hinaus, dann wird es für ihn sehr dünn. Dann kommt vielleicht nicht mehr die 3. Liga in Frage, die Dominik vorhin genannt hatte. Also er ist unter Beobachtung, so nenne ich es jetzt mal. Die Ligen dürfen es sich auf keinen Fall leisten, durchgereicht zu werden. Ich meine, das kann sich keiner leisten, aber dann hätte man die letzten 10 Jahre, von denen man 7 in der 2. und 3 in der 1. war, irgendwie zu einem schlechten Ende gebracht. Aber noch ist nichts entschieden. Wir sind am vierten Spieltag jetzt zum fünften. Geht es gegen Braunschweig, 17. gegen 18. Aber wahrscheinlich Sebastian Poulter, habe ich ja in Darmstadt gewesen, nichts gerissen. Er kommt zurück und trifft so, was male ich mir aus. Wer weiß.
Jetzt warten wir es mal ab. Aber es steht viel auf dem Spiel, sowohl für den Verein als auch für Florian Kohfeldt. Ich sage mal so, wenn das auch noch schiefgeht, dann bleibt ihm nur noch U17 beim DFB. Das ist wahrscheinlich die Endstation für Trainer wie Florian Kohfeldt. Wäre es dann zumindest. Aber jetzt wollen wir mal weg von diesen Trainerfragen. Hat denn Florian Kohfeldt überhaupt einen Kader, mit dem man auch in der Liga Erfolg haben kann?
Ja, gute Frage. Also wir haben viele ziehen lassen, die tatsächlich den Rucksack des Misserfolgs aufgeschnürt hatten. Und Torsten Lieberknecht meinte auch in einem Gespräch mit mir, dass ihm klar war, dass die Bundesliga schwer wird. Also sie hatten einfach kein Tempo. Das war für ihn so mit einem Knackpunkt der Spielzeit. Sie hätten demzufolge einige Spieler ziehen lassen müssen. Gleichwohl war da vielleicht nicht der Markt da für die, woanders unterzukommen. Ich rede jetzt von der Ausstiegssaison, also sprich der Transferperiode vor dem Einstieg in die 1. Bundesliga. Das heißt, sie sind mit einem Kader einfach gestartet, der nicht konkurrenzfähig war. Jetzt haben sie 10 bis 11 neue dazugeholt, von denen manche nicht so ganz ein klares Bild bei mir bislang hinterlassen hatten. Aus der französischen 2. Liga, Kylian Corredor. Dann aus der 1. niederländischen Liga, den Lidberg, ein Schwede. Das heißt, die zwei sind in Elbersberg auf dem Platz gestanden, waren aber überhaupt kein Faktor, was ich noch gar nicht vorhalten mag, weil die waren neu. Die waren auf den letzten Drucker verpflichtet, hatten erstmal im Pokalspiel gegen Nürnberg auf sich aufmerksam gemacht, aber dann sind sie mit untergegangen. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt viele Spieler, die neu sind. Lieberknecht meinte zu mir, das ist ein guter Mix aus mehr oder minder Arbeiter, aus Strategen, aus Tempospielern. Da gehört vielleicht ein Marseiller dazu, der aus Köln kam, aus der 3. Liga. Aber es sind halt irgendwie Spieler, die eine gewisse Fantasie anregen, aber die müssen es halt beweisen. Also man muss ihnen ein System an die Hand geben, das funktioniert. Man braucht eine Achse und die Achse sehe ich bislang noch nicht. So wie es in der Aufstiegssaison war, mit Melem, mit Zimmermann und mit Tietz. Sowas muss ich finden, aber ich kann bislang noch nicht sagen, wer es sein wird. Wilber, Wilber Wiener, war ein ganz klarer Kandidat gewesen. Was auf jeden Fall besser werden muss, ist die Defensive. Die scheint sich ja mit dem Erstliga-Aufstieg irgendwie in den Krisenmodus verabschiedet zu haben und noch nicht wieder herausgefunden haben, aus der Defensive Trubelay. Schwierig. Ob sie es kann, die Mannschaft, kann ich jetzt tatsächlich noch nicht beantworten, aber ich glaube, dass die Spieler schon dem Spiel was geben können. Sie sind jetzt keine Verlegenheitslösungen, sie wurden gewollt. Ein Kläfisch, wie vorhin schon gesagt, als so ein bisschen emotional Player, Leader weiß ich nicht, aber einer, der auf jeden Fall aufräumen kann. Da hätte Wil für meine Begriffe sehr gut dazu gepasst. Jetzt muss vielleicht ein Andreas Müller beweisen, ob er die 6. Position ausfüllen kann. Oder Christoph Kramer ist noch vertragslos und überlegt sich…
Wohl Marte für die Verteidigung.
Neben meiner TV-Karriere in Mainz, da habe ich ja gar nicht so weit weg, dann mache ich da noch mein Karriereendeleute ich ein auf der 6.
Aber musste denn der Umbruch so groß sein, deiner Meinung nach? Du hast es ja schon angesprochen.
Ja, ich glaube schon. Also ich glaube schon. Also im Endeffekt, du hast einen Kader, der keinen freudigen Tag mehr hatte, wenn man es mal genau nimmt, seit dem Mai 2023. Und wenn Lieberknecht sagte, es waren einfach einige Spieler, die an ihre Grenzen stießen. Und es zeigt sich ja auch jetzt, dass zumindest bis zum Wochenende ein Aaron Seidel und ein Janik Müller immer noch keinen Verein gefunden hatten. Fabian Schnell hat das Spiel in der 6. Liga. Also, manche Spieler sind einfach über ihrem Zenit gewesen. Oder sie haben als Mannschaft was erreicht, was aber in der ersten Liga nicht reproduzierbar war. Und ich glaube, um einfach auch ein neues Mindset reinzubringen, in das Team brauchtest du schon eine Blutauffrischung. Also, deshalb kann ich das schon verstehen, dass man nicht mit den altbewährten neuen Anlauf nimmt, sondern dass man jetzt tatsächlich auch umsattelt und die von Lieberknecht gewünschte vielleicht Schnelligkeit mitbringen. Auch ein bisschen eine Frechheit, also Luca Marseilla ist schon einer, glaube ich, der was drauf hat. Aber muss es jetzt auch in einem nicht mehr ganz jungen Alter eine Liga höher beweisen, als er es ein bisschen lang getan hat. Und die Neuzugänger aus dem Ausland, die kann ich nicht seriös einschätzen.
Ehrlicherweise, also bei Spielern, die man nicht spielen hat, sehen aus dem Ausland, die kann man schwer einschätzen. Aber es ist ja auch zum Beispiel Finn Lakenmacher von 1860. Den habe ich hier auch spielen sehen. Aber ob das in der 2. Liga reicht, das kann ich dir auch nicht sagen. Das können dir ja scouts selbst nicht immer sagen. Deswegen liegt man ja auch daneben. Deswegen brauchen wir das am 4. Spieltag hier noch nicht einordnen. Aber wenn wir auf der Suche sind nach einer Achse, hätte ich dann schon die Frage an dich, wer sind denn die MVPs im Team? Also strapaziert den Begriff jetzt ein bisschen über. Ich glaube, ich würde es nicht auf einen Spieler reduzieren, den man nicht rausnehmen darf. Aber wer sind die sollen? Und was ist denn dieses Teams aktuell?
Da hätte ich die zwei jetzt leider verletzten schon dazugerechnet. Mit Bader und mit Will, weil sie einfach auch Fußballer sind. Und zwar Fußballer, die mit dem Ball auch was kreieren können und nicht mehr oder weniger durch Laufstärke jetzt nur überzeugen oder durch Mentalität. Die brechen jetzt leider weg. Es scheint sehr so zu sein, dass Clemens Riedl jetzt eine größere Rolle einnehmen soll. Kohfeldt hat ja auch bei seiner Vorstellung gesagt, er mag es, junge Spieler zu entwickeln und hat auch namentlich Clemens Riedl genannt, der jetzt zuletzt Kapitän war mit seinen 21, glaube ich, in der Innenverteidigung. Also der hat Potenzial, der Junge, und dass er aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs stammt, macht das Ganze natürlich noch umso schöner. Aber ich glaube, wer immer noch ein gewichtiges Wort führt, ist Marcel Schuhn. Also er hat auch nach dem Elbersbergspiel klar benannt in seinen gewohnt emotionalen und rastischen Worten, was nicht funktioniert. Und derjenige, der quasi sich nicht den Arsch aufreißen kann, der soll sich verpissen. Also das waren schon auch starke Worte. Aber so kennt man ihn. Ich glaube, er hat immer noch ein großes Gewicht in der Kabine. Dann brauchst du natürlich jemanden im Mittelfeld, der überzeugt. Vielleicht ist es dann doch ein Klefisch, aber ich kann es noch nicht so wirklich sagen. Und vorne hast du halt ein, Louis wollte ich schon sagen, ein Hornby, der Vorname ist mir jetzt entfallen.
Frazer.
Frazer, genau. Der aber immer noch nicht so richtig angekommen ist, auch verletzungsgeplagt war. Dann Oscar Wilhelmson. Da würde ich vielleicht drauf gehen. Wenn der mal wirklich von seinen WW-Chin, jetzt nicht die größten Verletzungen, aber immer wieder aus dem Rhythmus rausgerissen, wenn der mal Zeit hat, über Wochen hinweg Anlauf zu nehmen, wie er es auch zum Schluss in der ersten Liga gezeigt hat, finde ich, dann ist er schon jemand, auf den man setzen kann. Und in der Offensive mit Lieberk, mit Koidor, mit Lakenmacher, mit Wilhelmsson oder auch mit Hornby, da hat man schon fünf Spielertypen, die unterschiedliche Profile mitbringen. Das hat Kohfeldt auch gesagt, da hat er Optionen im Angriff oder im Offensivspiel, die durchaus auch ein bisschen eine Unberechenbarkeit für den Gegner mitbringen. Aber wenn du jetzt nach Säulen fragst, also ich hoffe, dass Christoph Zimmermann wieder irgendwann mal ein Faktor wird, dann gerne ihn. Clemens Riedl scheint aufgebaut zu werden und vorne ein Wilhelmsson, der hoffentlich zeigt über eine längere Strecke, dass er in Form und in Schuss kommt. Und ja, ein bisschen so Richtung Karriere-Ende stielen ja schon Klaus Giazula und auch Tobias Kempel. Die sind nicht, glaube ich, unwichtig geworden, aber dass ihre Spielzeiten weniger werden, das war auch schon bei Lieberknecht rauszuhören. Mal gespannt, was Kohfeldt mit ihnen vorhat. Aber Lieberknecht wollte sie im Team haben, um auch der Mannschaft was mitzugeben, also den Spielern, die jetzt in die Verantwortung reinwachsen, denen zu vermitteln, worauf es ankommt. Also hat sie, glaube ich, eher so als Übergangsspieler bezeichnet. Die wissen, die Karriere ist endlich. Aber dass sie dennoch in der Kabinenfaktor spielen, ich glaube, sie sind auch beide im Mannschaftsrat. Und die sind also im Mitzimmermann, glaube ich, so drei Campen in der Kabine, wenn die auch schon dem Team was mitgeben.
Interessant. Und jetzt geht's gegen Braunschweig am Samstag um 13 Uhr. Zum 15. Mal betont einer von uns beiden, es ist früh in der Saison. Aber was ist dein Gefühl? Schafft Darmstadt jetzt, mit einem Anlauf von wahrscheinlich einigen Wochen, endlich die Wende zu nachhaltig positiveren Gefühlen? Verschwindet die schlechte Laune, die irgendwie unterschwellig fast immer da war?
Ich glaube, es ist ein fragiles Etwas, was wir vorfinden. Ich glaube nicht, dass es mit einem Sieg gegen Braunschweig weggewischt wird. Also ich finde, ein erfolgreicher Auftakt gegen Braunschweig ist für alle wichtig. Für Kohfeldt und Astellinne, für das Präsidium auch zu wissen, ah, schonmal nicht schlecht, was hier startet. Und der Mannschaft auch, dass sie wissen, hier ist ein neuer vorne dran, der erzählt vielleicht nicht immer wieder dieselben Geschichten. Ohne das jetzt Lieberknecht nachzusagen. Aber ich glaube, irgendwann ist man am Ende mit seiner Motivationskunst. Also wenn man merkt, hier ist ein Coach, der bringt eine Idee rein und die verfängt sofort, dann kann das ja mit einer Mannschaft was machen. Aber dennoch, ich glaube, da muss längerer, nachhaltiger Erfolg her. Und der kann mit Braunschweig seinen Ausgang nehmen. Aber dann folgt auch irgendwann Schalke und Karlsruhe und so weiter. Also es wird nicht einfach. Die 2. Liga finde ich enorm stark. Und man sieht, dass viele oder jeder jeden schlagen kann. Und deshalb ist es nach wie vor ein fragiles Etwas.
Vielleicht kann dir Dominik erklären, wie das in Heimspielen gegen Braunschweig läuft. Denn das war vielleicht das überzeugendste Spiel bisher von Schalke 04. Kannst du mir jetzt gleich sagen, Dominik, das war nämlich der Auftakt in der Saison, ein 5 zu 1. Und das, obwohl auch bei Schalke die Aufregung– naturgemäß ist es Schalke 04– schon wieder relativ hoch war, auch vor der Saison, als noch keine Minute gespielt war. Also wie hat denn der Schalke geschafft, Braunschweig so wegzufielen?
In dem sie vor allem gut aus der Kabine gekommen sind, glaube ich. Also es stand ja, glaube ich, zur Halbzeit schon 2-0, ja. Da haben sie aber noch nicht wahnsinnig überzeugend gespielt. Das kam erst aus meiner Sicht in der zweiten Halbzeit. Und weil sie da sehr direkt einfach nach vorne gespielt haben. Also sie haben weniger abwartend gespielt, als sie es dann doch oftmals tun, haben die Bälle eben sehr vertikal nach vorne gespielt und hatten dann halt auch einfach, ja, das Momentum, das oft zitierte, dass eben Karaman und Zilla dann auch die Chancen sehr gut verwertet haben im Spiel gegen Braunschweig. Das ist ja auch so eine Sache, die sich jetzt dann in den Spielen anschließend an Braunschweig so ein bisschen durchgezogen hat. Ich glaube, Schalke hat mit die höchste oder sogar die höchste x, also den mit höchsten oder höchsten xg-Wert in der 2. Liga, aber unterm Strich kommen da halt zu wenig zählbares an Toren und vor allem an Punkten bei rum. Weil eigentlich hast du mit Karamann und Silla zwei abschlussstarke Spieler voll drin, wobei Silla gegen Köln wirklich indisponiert war. Und da hast du dann gemerkt, dass Chef Koch Manga hat super gekocht im Sommer, aber hat eben so ein bisschen den Sturm vernachlässigt. Ja, ich weine Sebastian Poulter nicht unbedingt eine Träne hinterher. Aber man hätte vielleicht doch nochmal für einen richtigen Neuner sorgen können. Weil, den konntest du zum Beispiel gegen Köln, als du gesehen hast, okay, Silla, der eigentlich auch lieber über die Flügel kommt und die vergangenen Saison in der Ligue 2 vor allem über die Flügel auf sich aufmerksam gemacht hat, der kommt einfach nicht ins Spiel gegen Köln als Stoßstürmer. Hattest du halt einfach auf der Bankblatt des Original keinen Stürmer, den du nachschieben konntest. Und da bin ich halt auch mal gespannt, wie sie diese Lücke doch, also zumindest bis zur Winter-Transferperiode irgendwie schließen wollen. Weil, so wie ich das jetzt beobachte, gibt es jetzt zumindest auch außer Bund nicht den einen, der sich aufträgt, Emil Höllund. Ja, auf den setzen sehr viel und ich hoffe natürlich auch, dass er sich ähnlich entwickelt wie sein Bruder Rasmus, wobei der natürlich für Men United-Verhältnisse jetzt auch kein Überflieger ist. Aber ja, das fehlt mir da doch an Qualität aus der zweiten Reihe im Sturm. Und ich glaube, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, das ist auch so der Grund, warum es dann bisher doch nur bei einem Schützenfest, und zwar gegen aus meiner Sicht Abstiegskandidat Nummer 1, einfach brancheweit geblieben ist.
Danach dann 1 zu 3 in Nürnberg verloren beim Club, der endlich mal wieder aus Sicht der Klubberer gegen Schalke gewinnen konnte, gegen Ahlen weitergekommen im Pokal, ein 2 zu 2 gegen Magdeburg, fast schon mit Ansage, und dann eben dieses 1 zu 3, bei dem man fies verpfiffen wurde, weil die DFL– und das ist ja bekannt– Schalke 04 hasst. Da müssen wir, glaube ich, gar nicht tiefer in die Diskussion gehen, das ist eindeutig. Das lassen wir hier auch einfach so stehen. Wie würdest du aber denn generell jetzt diesen Start bewerten?
Also ich bin zum Spiel nach Köln gefahren und habe gesagt, okay, also das ist jetzt so ein Spiel, danach bist du den Saisonstart richten. Ich glaube, die Ausgangssituation vor Köln war ein Sieg, ein Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Du hattest mit einem Sieg oben anschließen Köln. Und es ist halt genau das andere gekommen, es gab eine Niederlage, jetzt ist man auf Platz 12. Und mein Sitznachbar in der Veltins Arena, die begrüßte an Ziggy, meinte, ja, das wird eine Saison wie letztes Jahr. So negativ bin ich noch nicht.
Sehr gut.
Aber es ist natürlich, wenn du auf die Tabelle schaust, nach vier Spieltagen und da stehen halt vier Punkte, jetzt schon zwei Niederlagen, ist das ein bisschen ernüchternd. Eben weil, ich glaube, trotz erst mal dieser Soap-Opera, die sich da aufbraut zwischen Manga und Geraz, da konnten wir bestimmt gleich auch noch zu sprechen, weil die Stimmung rund um den Verein doch recht gut, weil eben mit einer neuen Strategie verpflichtet wurde, ich glaube, das Wort Geduld in mehreren Vereinsmitteilungen, ob Video oder schriftlich, so oft wie in den vergangenen 80 bis 100 Jahren auf Schalke nicht benutzt wurde und das hat, glaube ich, vielen Supportern einfach ein gutes Gefühl gegeben, dass jetzt Leute sind, die mit etwas mehr Weitsicht arbeiten. Dass man ja auch an Geraz festgehalten hat, war schon ein gutes Zeichen, das war auch recht lange nicht klar, sodass man eigentlich mit einem guten Gefühl in die Saison gestartet ist. Und jetzt ist eben so ein Break-Even-Point. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das bildstimmig ist, aber halt so ein Punkt bis zur nächsten Länderspielpause im Oktober wird sich eben dieses gerade schwammige Bild, glaube ich, verfestigen. Also kann es eine Saison sein, die besser aussieht und vielleicht so eine Transit-Saison, wo man sagt, okay, aber nächstes Jahr hat man wirklich ein gefestigtes Schalke, das dann auch so Gott will, so Gott der Fußballgott Rudi Assauer will, wieder um den Aufstieg spielt? Oder ist es halt eine Saison, wo man wieder irgendwie im Mittelfeld rumdumpelt und froh sein kann, wenn das sportliche quasi auch die kleinste Problematik im Verein ist?
Und ginge das denn überhaupt, würde das Schalke 04 aushalten, jetzt drin zu bleiben und in der nächsten Saison vielleicht, um den Aufstieg mitzuspielen, was ja noch nicht der Aufstieg wäre?
Also zumindest ist das ja die offizielle Kommunikation von den Verantwortlichen, also sowohl vom Vorstand als auch von der sportlichen Leitung um Marc Wilmutz und Ben Manga, dass es weiterhin diesen 3-Jahresplan gibt, also dass man Schalke problemlos 3 Jahre auch finanziell in der 2. Liga halten kann, dass man nichts übers Knie brechen will, dass man das Wort Aufstieg auch partout nicht in den Mund nehmen will, dass die sozusagen das Saisonziel ist, sich zu verbessern, dass man eben eine Mannschaft formt, die zu Größerem in der Lage ist. Von daher glaube ich auch nicht, dass Schalke groß mit dem Aufstieg irgendwie diese Saison schon was zu tun haben wird, aber ich kann mir eben gut vorstellen, dass sie in so eine Gruppe aufschließen könnten, wenn sich jetzt ein paar Schrauben verfestigen, von denen man dann sagen kann, okay, die spielt dann die nächste Saison um den Aufstieg.
Lass mal beim Personal bleiben, weil ich finde, sportlich ist das so diffus, dass man da wirklich einfach sagen muss, da muss man eigentlich so die Segel streichen und sagen, so ähnlich, wie du es gerade eingeschätzt hast, komm, da müssen wir jetzt noch mal bis zur nächsten Länderspielpause in Ruhe draufgucken und dann kann man das besser bewerten. Aber es gab ja eben sehr viel Umbruch. Unter anderem ist Ben Manga mit seinem Team– ja, eingefallen ist jetzt so negativ besetzt– aber er ist aufgeschlagen bei Schalke 04. Da haben sich ja auch sehr viele drüber gefreut. Aber es war ja nicht der einzige Stuhl, der gerückt wurde bei Schalke 04. Kannst du uns mal zusammenfassen, was sind quasi die wichtigen Dinge, die sich verändert haben im Vergleich zur letzten Saison, die man mitbekommen haben muss?
Ja, ich glaube, Ben Manga ist auf jeden Fall die wichtigste Personalie, die im Sommer quasi geschehen ist. Und da würde ich auch alle Transfers quasi außen vor halten. Sondern da ist jetzt jemand reingekommen, der, wie du es gesagt hast, auch ein ganzes Team mitgebracht hat. Das war ja auch lange Zeit einfach ein Punkt oder eine Abteilung auf Schalke, die ein bisschen vernachlässigt oder so wie die Abteilung ist. Genau, das scouting. Da ist jetzt wirklich so eine Struktur drin. Es gibt bestimmte Personen, die bestimmte Märkte bedienen. Ich finde es auch sehr spannend, dass man so klar kommuniziert hat, okay, wir wollen jetzt folgendes Profil an Spiele scouten. Also jung U23 mit großem Potenzial, am besten schon mit Erstliga-Erfahrung in der Heimat, gerne auch aus Afrika und Südamerika. Da ist ja exemplarisch dieser Steve Noot, der aus dem Nichts gekommen ist, aus dem Cameroon, der noch nicht mal einen Transfer-Eintrag hatte und wo Ben Manga sich eben hinstellt und sagt, ich kenne den Jungen schon seit fünf Jahren und ich bin überzeugt von ihm. Und da gibt es ja einige Transfers. Und das ist eben auch nochmal diese Positivität, die zu Beginn der Saison um den Verein wahrzunehmen war, hingen ganz viel an dieser Personalie Ben Manga, weil es mal wieder den Fans vermittelt hat, da kommt jemand wirklich mit Fachexpertise. Also nicht jemand, der hausentern hochgezogen wurde, niemand, der irgendwie aus Klingelei in den Fall gekommen ist, sondern wirklich jemand, der Fachexpertise mitbringt, der Netzwerk mitbringt, der Weitsicht mitbringt. Und das hat, glaube ich, viele Leute angezündet. Und es gibt ja so einen kleinen Ausschnitt. Als Christopher Antwia Jay, glaube ich, war das seine Vertragsunterschrift auf Schalke hatte, wurde er natürlich von Schalker Vereinskameras begleitet. Und Christina Will-Hamas, die Finanzvorständin auf Schalke, hat ja vor allem in Boulevard etwas dunkles Bild, dunkles Image abbekommen, so von wegen sie spart Schalke Pleite und so weiter und so fort. Oh Gott, nee, ehrlich?
Das habe ich ja gar nicht mitgeschrieben.
Ja, ja.
Da kommt mal jemand mit finanzieller Expertise und einem sinnvollen Plan und dann heißt es– ach, das ist ja fantastisch.
Sie spart Schalke Pleite und sie will ja kein Geld freigeben. Und vor nichts kommt nichts. Und sie ist sowieso die große Hexe und wird Schalke zu runterrichten. Also, so nachdenklich davon, dass ich das so nicht glaube. Aber das ist quasi auch, was man dann halt so an Rumoren wahrnimmt, wenn man dann am Bergerfeld ist und irgendwie am Spieltag so den Fans lauscht. Aber auf jeden Fall gab es in dieser, sag ich mal, Doku zum Anfiya J, glaube ich, Transfer, eine sehr, also eine sehr, sehr kleine Szene, die dann aber der Schalker Bubble total angezündet wurde, weil Ben Manga irgendwie zu Anfiya J gesagt hat, hier, das ist die wichtigste Frau Schalke, stell dich gut mit ihr. Und Rülhamas dann so ein bisschen gekichert hat und irgendwie Ben Manga geknüpft hat und gesagt hat so, ach, hör doch auf, Ben. Und irgendwie so ein Alarm gesagt, ah ja, hier, der reißt den ganzen Laden rum und der hat Rülhamas jetzt auch angezündet für seine Idee und jetzt gibt es auch endlich wieder Geld. Und der nächste Moises Caicedo ist schon im Anflug. Und wir nehmen hier in drei Jahren schon wieder die Champions League aus am Ende, so wie halt Schalke.
Also eine Sache ist gleich geblieben, es reichen selbst kleinste Dinge, um wieder für euphorie zu sagen.
Genau so wie also kleinste Dinge auf Schalke herrscht jetzt auch große Begeisterung, weil der Verein sich dazu entschieden hat, Wasser an Spieltagen für zwei Euro anzubieten, statt 4,60 Euro, wie in der Vorsaison. Das ist aber gut. Super, da habe ich auch dankbar das Angebot angenommen, gerade bei den Temperaturen an den vergangenen Spieltagen. Aber da wurde halt auch schon wieder sehr theatralisch und sehr Schalke-esque nach außen verkauft. Der Verein hat es endlich verstanden und jetzt geht es voran. Wir sind der Konkurrenz voraus. Und wir blicken irgendwie schon in die Zukunft, während die anderen ihre Fans noch auseinandernehmen. Ausnehmen, genau, nicht auseinandernehmen, ausnehmen. Und da hat Ben Manga bestimmt auch seine Aktien drin. Also was man da nicht will, dass man aus solchen Kleinigkeiten rausliest.
Ich kenne Schalke gut genug, um zu fragen, wie heiß denn jetzt dieses Wasser? Ist es Grubenelexie oder was hat man sich dafür ausgedacht?
Oh, siehst du, vielleicht solltest du mal ein paar Leute in der Schalke-Marketing-Abteilung kontaktieren, weil so weit sind sie noch nicht gekommen. Also es ist immer noch das Wasser des Schalker Wassersponsoren. Aber das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, siehst du. Weil man hat ja auch in der vergangenen Saison bei Schalke gesehen, die bringen da so eine halbgarre Retro-Kollektion raus mit dem, mit so einem alten Logo und die Seite bricht zusammen und sie müssen irgendwie 10.000 Nachbestellungen machen. Die Leute warten vier Monate auf ihre bestellten Klamotten und dabei war es halt wirklich einfach nur quasi Adidas-Stangenware und da wurde das alte Logo drauf gekloppt. Aber der Verein ist halt so positiv gekloppt, dass du den Fans wirklich eigentlich alles verkaufen kannst, was auf der einen Seite eigentlich traurig ist, aber auf der anderen Seite auch, glaube ich, dass es wahrscheinlich immer noch am Leben erhält. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Um quasi den Kreis zu schließen. Ich glaube, deshalb kann so eine Person wie Ben Manga mit den Dingen, die er bis hierhin gemacht hat, eben auch so ein Umfeld anzünden und für sich gewinnen, weil sie halt einfach nach was Großen, nach der Zukunft, nach Erfolg lächzen. Und wenn eben jemand das gut zu verkaufen weiß, dann kommt er da mit, also auf Schalke, auf sehr näherhaften, nahhaften Boden.
Ja, also das muss man auf jeden Fall noch mal betonen. Also bei allem, ich habe mich jetzt ja auch lustig gemacht über diesen Marketingkram, der da auf Schalke eben sehr häufig passiert ist, vor allem in der Vergangenheit natürlich. Aber 164 Millionen Euro Rohergebnis in der Saison 2022-23, das war das zehntbeste Ergebnis im deutschen Profifußball. Daher kommt überhaupt die Möglichkeit, drei Jahre in der 2. Liga finanzieren zu können. Denn ansonsten wissen wir ja, die Schulden sind ebenso riesig bei Schalke 04. Aber wenn eben vorne die ganze Zeit was reinkommt, dann kannst du hinten auch deine Kredite bedienen und ein bisschen was noch verbrennen in deinem Personaletat. Jetzt ist das aber natürlich zweischneidig zu sehen. Also Ben Manga hat natürlich einen sehr guten Track-Racket. Also er war vorher beim VfB Stuttgart, vor allem bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Da hat er richtig mit seinen mit von ihm gescouteten Spielern eine Ära geprägt. Die Wortvorzeit habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich verfolgt. Da kann ich mir keinen Urteil zu erlauben. Aber es liegt ja auch eine kleine Gefahr darin, wenn man sich so jemandem und seinem Team– ich weiß nicht, ob Auslieferung zu viel ist. Wie würdest du darauf blicken, auf ein Abhängigkeitsverhältnis, was man definitiv hat?
Ja, absolut. Das sind die Verfehlungen in der Vergangenheit, dass man sich grundsätzlich sich in scouting schon besser aufgestellt hat und generell in der sportlichen Leitung besser aufgestellt hat. Ich finde es erstmal grundsätzlich gut, dass man eben Ben Manga plus Team geholt hat, weil es eben eingespielt ist. Du ein ganz großes Netzwerk aktivieren kannst. Also nicht wieder eine Person, die quasi von scouting bis Ansprache und Vertragsabschluss alles machen muss, sondern dass du das auf viele Schultern aufteilst. Aber natürlich besteht die Gefahr, Ben Manga verwirft sich mit Vorstandsvorsitzenden Tillmann und ist in sechs Monaten wieder weg und dann natürlich mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit auch sein ganzes Team und du stehst wieder bei Null. Aber die Frage ist ja, was wäre die Alternative gewesen? Also es war ja schon gegen Ende der vergangenen Saison klar, dass Ben Manga kommt und da war ja auch klar, ohne sein Team kommt er eben nicht. Also er wird nicht alleine kommen. Da wurde dann ja peu à peu die Schalker scouting-abteilung mehr oder weniger aufgelöst. Also ein Mitarbeiter nach dem anderen ging, bis quasi sozusagen eine weiße Fläche entstanden ist, auf der dann Ben Manga anfangen konnte zu malen und seine Musiksteine zu setzen. Und dementsprechend war Schalke einfach in so einer Verhandlungssituation oder generell in so einer sportlichen Situation, dass das, glaube ich, egal wie die Saison jetzt weiterläuft, aber stand heute, die beste Entscheidung war, so eine fähige Person plus Netzwerk reinzuholen und dann eben zu hoffen, einfach, dass es drei Jahre plus hält und eben nicht das nächste Gasspiel ist. Weil das hatten wir jetzt auf Schalke zu Hauf, sei es ein André Hechelmann gewesen, sei es ein Jochen Schneider, noch ein Christian Heidel, das war ja alles nicht von Dauer. Und ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass dieser Schattenung von Rudi Assauer dann doch mit der Zeit jetzt abnimmt, weil man auch eben sieht, der Fußball hat sich so massiv entwickelt, dass so eine Persönlichkeit wie Assauer da immer weniger Platz hätte, also einfach diese Alleinherrschaft, diese Geballte macht. Gar nicht jetzt so eher als Charakter. Ich glaube, der wird in der Presse und bei den Fans weiterhin punkten. Aber man merkt halt eben auch, dass Schalke als sehr traditionelles Umfeld immer sozusagen offener ist für solche Ansätze, für so etwas Dezentrales, wie es eben Manga fährt. Und da war ja auch zu Anfangszeit, also auch bevor Manga wirklich offiziell vorgestellt wurde, war ja da auch schon das Getuschel groß. Wie wird er mit Mark Wilmots zusammenarbeiten? Mark Wilmots ist ja offiziell Sportdirektor. Ben Manga ist, glaube ich, Direktor scouting und Knappenschmiede. Und dabei auch dann lange gut gemunt, was, ok, berichtet er an Mark Wilmots. Wird Mark Wilmots sich quasi enteignet fühlen durch Ben Manga, der eigentlich ihm alles zuarbeitet. Und Mark Wilmots kommt dann nur zu den Fotoshootings mit den neuen Spielern. Wie soll das funktionieren? Und da ist ja eigentlich recht positiv wahrzunehmen, dass die beiden offenbar, zumindest so, wie ich es einschätzen kann, einen sehr offenen Diskurs führen. Es relativ wenig echte Alleingänge gibt von Ben Manga. Und Mark Wilmots ihn ja auch tatsächlich in der ganzen Manga-Gerads-Posse– nächster Spoiler– doch den Rücken stärkt oder ihm zumindest nicht in den Rücken fällt, wo er auch lange getuschelt wurde. Okay, Wilmots und Gerads, zwei Belgier, die, so weit ich weiß, sogar noch zusammen in der Nationalmannschaft gespielt haben, also die sich kennen und schätzen, da wird auch Wilmots bestimmt zu seinem Landsmann halten, so wie das halt so ist. Und das scheint ja überhaupt nicht der Fall zu sein, sondern Wilmots tritt, was man jetzt auch in der vergangenen Saison gar nicht so gedacht hätte, als recht besonderer Mittler auf, was ich als überraschend gute Entwicklung, Charaktereinwicklung wahrnehme, weil so nach den ersten Wochen Marc Wilmots Sportdirektor gerade in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung dachte ich, uiuiui, was haben sie denn da bloß gemacht? Weil das war ja phasenweise, also ich wusste ja gefühlt nicht, was er gestern erzählt hat und hat sich dann selbst widersprochen. Und ich glaube, da ist er dann auch in diese Rolle gut reingewachsen.
Okay, aber was ist denn jetzt dann los mit Karel Gerrits? Was ist die Kritik? Was weiß man? Ist es jetzt hier auch wieder nur Boulevard oder ist da was dran? Ich habe es ehrlicherweise nur so ganz am Rande mitbekommen.
Also der Kern dieser ganzen Posse ist, dass Ben Manga zwei junge, talentierte Innenverteidiger verpflichtet hat. Philippe Sanches und Martin Vazinski. Philippe Sanches aus meiner Sicht eigentlich ein Spieler vom Profil Königstransfer. Hat zwei Jahre erst argentinische Liga schon in den Beinen bei Gymnasia La Plata, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Martin Vazinski auch U20-Nationalspieler Belgiens. Hat auch schon erste Liga-Erfahrung bei Charleroi, wenn ich richtig informiert bin, ja. Und Ben Manga ist sehr begeistert von den Beinen, also ist sehr vokal in seiner Erzeugung von diesen Spielern. Und hat gerade auch, weil jetzt Thomas Kallasch, der sich ja letzte Saison als absoluter Abwehrchef herausgespielt hat, verletzungsbedingt länger ausfällt, die beiden auch so ein bisschen in die Position gebracht, verbal in Richtung Presse. Wir haben ja zwei junge Spieler, die lauern ja nur auf diese Chance. Diese Chance haben sie von Karel Gerač bisher nicht wirklich bekommen. Karel Gerač setzt lieber auf Ibrahim Assisi, der ja schon zwei Trainer vor ihm zu Weißblut und Verzweiflung gebracht hat, weil er zwar ein hoch veranlagter Spieler, aber ein Spieler, der eben jetzt, glaube ich, in der dritten Saison auf Schalke nicht auf ein konditionelles und auch auf ein taktisches Niveau kommt, dass er wirklich unangefochtener Stammspieler wäre. Daneben lässt er Ron Schallenberg spielen in der Innenverteidigung, den er quasi die verlangene Saison umgeschult hat, vom Sechser zum Innenverteidiger, der das sehr gut gemacht hat, der auf Schalke so eine Libereau-Position einnimmt, also oftmals auch ohne direkten Gegenspieler agiert in der Verteidigung, den Spielaufbau von sehr tief, also gefühlt direkt vom Torwart, bekommt den Ball, ankurbelt. Und darauf hat sich eben Gerards eingespielt. Und man hat eben sowohl gegen Köln als auch in Magdeburg und schon gegen den Klub gesehen, das ist halt nicht ganz sattelfest. Und Ben Manga, da kann man ihn jetzt diskutieren, aus meiner Sicht auch so ein bisschen unnötigerweise, dann nochmal vor die Presse gestellt und gesagt, explizit zu Philippe Sanches, ein Spieler, der gegen Boca Juniors im Bomboleira spielt und über 90 Minuten spielt, der will schon kein Problem haben, gegen Magdeburg oder in Magdeburg oder gegen den 1. FC Köln aufzulaufen. Und das aus meiner Sicht so ein bisschen die Entscheidung des Trainers kritisiert und den Trainer aus meiner Sicht ja auch ein wenig damit angezählt, weil er sagt, er oder ich habe daraus rausgelesen, Ben Manga traut dem Trainer nicht zu, das Potenzial der Spieler korrekt einzuschätzen. Karel Geraz hat dann wiederum gesagt, das sind nicht seine Worte. Er sieht das, was jeden Tag auf dem Platz geschieht und keiner macht sich so viele Sorgen und nimmt sich Schalke 04 wie er. Und er wird niemanden jetzt protigieren, weil es von außen hereingetragen wird. Er will seine Entscheidung finden. Und jetzt ist quasi die große Erwartung, was wird gegen den KSC jetzt am Wochenende passieren. Wird das Wiederassist Schallenberg heißen in der Innenverteidigung? Geraz bleibt sich treu und vertraut den Spielern, denen er ihm vertrauen möchte. Oder wird er vielleicht doch einlenken und Wasinski oder Sanchos mal von Beginn an Minuten in der Liga ergeben? Die beiden haben ja ein Pokal von Beginn an gespielt. Wasinski hat jetzt unter der Woche im Testspiel gegen Nagbreda oder vergangene Woche im Testspiel gegen Nagbreda auch gespielt. Hat das eine Gegentor mit einem Stoppfehler günstigt, dann aber sein Fehler selbst mit einem guten Pressing-Verhalten wieder gut gemacht und eigene Treffer zum Sieg. Ich bin also auch ein bisschen zuwiegespalten, weil ich auf der einen Seite eigentlich schon einen starken Trainer haben möchte, der sagt, ich habe meine Vorstellung, ich vertraue auf mich und das, was ich eben auch im Training sehe und ich lasse mich nicht reinreden. Andererseits kann ich es aber auch nachvollziehen, wenn man sagt, okay, er hat dieses Spielermaterial, was aus meiner Sicht absolut zweitligafähig ist, was sich angeboten hat, mit guten Leistungen im Pokal und in den Testspielen und er setzt so gar nicht darauf, gerade eben, wenn er sieht, dass die Innenverteidigung, wie sie jetzt in den vergangenen drei Spielen war, nicht sattelfest ist. Er hat heute in der Spieltags-PK, als die Frage wieder zu den Innenverteidiger-Duo, Innenverteidiger-Pärchen kam, gesagt, na ja, er wird sich seine Gedanken machen und er kann auch verstehen, wenn die Leute sagen, dass man da nicht sattelfest war. Aber eine Innenverteidigung wird auch nicht sattelfester, wenn man sie in vier Wochen dreimal wechselt. Das klang jetzt für mich erstmal so raus, als ob wir dann gegen den KSC wieder das Innenverteidiger-Pärchen Cissé und Schallenberg bekommen. Sollten sie zu Null spielen, Schalke gewinnt gegen den KSC, dann wird sich Geraz natürlich auch zurecht hinstellen und sagen, ich habe es dir gesagt, gib mir Zeit, ich weiß, was ich mache. Wenn Schalke da wieder zwei oder drei Gegentore kassiert, dann wird die Hütte, glaube ich, ganz anders brennen, weil dann der Druck auf Geraz sowohl mit Blick auf die Tabelle als auch, dann kann man es ihm halt auch als Sturheit auslegen, ein bisschen größer werden dürfte.
Also, dass das inhaltlich natürlich eine valide Debatte ist, die auch letztlich an die zukünftige Strategie von Schalke heranrührt, das, denke ich, kann man sehr leicht verargumentieren. Aber warum, Dominik, muss das denn öffentlich stattfinden? An wem liegt das?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich habe ja gerade gesagt, also ich fand diese Aussage von Manga mit Sanches, der wird ja wohl gegen Wachtelburg spielen können, war nicht ein bisschen übers Ziel hinausgeschossen. Unterm Strich, glaube ich, wissen wir halt alle, wie das Umfeld auf Schalke ist. Da laufen halt mehr als zwei… Also liegt es an den Medien.
Kann man sowas nicht intern machen?
Ich glaube, der Mediendruck auf Schalke ist auf jeden Fall ein anderer als oder größerer als bei anderen Zweitliga-Standorten. Und wenn dann Ben Manga eben drei, vier Fragen ausweichen kann, wird dann halt der Druck vielleicht so groß, dass er in der fünften Frage oder auf die fünfte Frage mit Klartext antwortet oder mit so viel Klartext, wie er sich leisten kann in seiner Position. Ja, ich glaube, wir werden nie zu dem Umstand kommen, dass auf Schalke über– es sind ja dann doch auch sportliche Themen– so gar nicht in der Öffentlichkeit mit Aussagen von Verantwortlichen debattiert, diskutiert wird. Ich glaube, das ist utopisch, weil eben, wie gesagt, da laufen so viele Medienvertreter rum, das interessiert so viele Leute. Natürlich wissen auch die Verantwortlichen, dass sie sich da profilieren können durch bestimmte Aussagen, dass sie bestimmte Stimmungen bedienen können. Und ich glaube, wir werden dann, wie gesagt, nie dazu kommen, dass es so eine Diskussion aus Fernkreisen gibt und da es komplette Stille am Jens-Von-Zorra-Weg geben wird und dass das dann einfach totgeschwiegen wird. Weil dann, glaube ich, ist sogar die Gefahr größer, dass der Boulevard sein eigenes Süppchen daraus kocht und das dann wieder heißt ja Schalke schweigt und was bedeutet das und das kann nichts Gutes bedeuten. Und das gab es bestimmt schon mal in der Vergangenheit und da ist das und das passiert und das blüht uns jetzt auch.
Also ich verstehe deinen Punkt und da ist ganz sicherlich was wahres dran, aber ich finde es schon bemerkenswert, dass Schalke da in eine Situation reingekommen ist, in der es auf jeden Fall mindestens einen Verlierer geben wird. Wahrscheinlich sogar mehr und das kann sein, dass das beteiligte Spieler sind, sowohl diejenigen, die spielen sollen, als auch die, die jetzt gerade spielen. Es ist relativ wahrscheinlich, dass es der Trainer ist, Karol Gerrads, denn das ist eine Kompetenzüberschreitung von Ben Manga. Sowas geht auf Dauer nie gut im Fußball, das kann man so sagen. Und ehrlicherweise finde ich auch, dass Ben Manga dann vielleicht mal ein Interview weniger geben könnte. Also wobei, ich möchte anerkennen, was du sagst. Also es stimmt natürlich, dass es bei Schalke schwierig ist, Dinge unter der Decke zu halten, aber es gibt immer die Option, es gibt die Option, nichts zu sagen. Und selbst wenn der Boulevard, in Anführungszeichen, sich dann was ausdenkt, dann lasst sie sich was ausdenken. Also ich erlebe es gerade, wie es hier ist. Beim FC Bayern, also ich bin ja in München ansässig. Ich weiß nicht, ob er es durchhalten kann, aber Marseille Compagnie hat auf die ersten 15 Fragen nach möglichen Transfers, hat er immer gesagt, das ist ein Thema, da werde ich nichts zu sagen. Und mehr hat er nicht dazu gesagt. 15 Mal, in verschiedenen Variationen. Und tatsächlich irgendwann hat es aufgehört. Jetzt muss Max Eberl häufiger in den Mixed Zone, weil natürlich die MedienvertreterInnen haben trotzdem ihre Fragen. Aber das fand ich interessant, weil der Kontrast auch zu Thomas Tuche so groß war. Und wie gesagt, jetzt mit aller Vorsicht muss man mal gucken, kann er das auch durchhalten, wenn es richtig brennt hier in München beim FC Bayern und so weiter und so fort. Aber es ist schon möglich zu sagen, äußere ich mich nicht zu, das machen wir nur intern, naja.
Ja, ich glaube, du hast da also viele Sachen angesprochen, die sich halt in dieser Gemengelage befinden. Also man muss Schalke schon auch so gut halten, dass viele Transfers kaum, gar nicht, sehr spät an die Presse durchgesteckt worden sind.
Ja, sehr gut.
Also der heiße Moussa Sila oder Janik Bachmann hat auch keine auf dem Schirm. Adrian Gantenbein wurde super schnell, super früh bekanntgegeben.
Ist eh mein Lieblingsspieler bei euch. Mein Name ist ja Gantenbein, aber das ist hin.
Also von daher glaube ich, machen sie das alles in einem besser als in den vergangenen Zeiten auf Schalke. Aber wie gesagt, ganz die Presse nicht bedienen, wird auf Schalke nicht funktionieren. Und ich glaube halt, wie gesagt, diese eine Aussage von Manga mit Philippe Sanches, Wasinski, das war ein ganz klarer Ausrutscher. Ich glaube, das wird er in seinem stillen Kämmerlein auch als solcher, reflektiert haben. Ich glaube, bei ihm kam halt in dem Moment vielleicht auch so ein bisschen Frustration durch, weil Peratz natürlich auch mit Mangas Strategie spielt, indem er sie halt nicht einsetzt oder kaum einsetzt. Ich habe es ja vorhin schon aufgezeichnet, dass es eben Ben Mangas selling point, ich komme rein, ich bringe euch in ruhigem Fahrwasser mittelfristig wieder dorthin, wo ihr hingehört, als einer der größten Vereine Deutschlands, als einer der Mitglieder stärksten Vereine Europas. Und wenn Karel Gerrads sagt, das ist ja alles schön und gut, aber ich sehe die beiden nicht als Spieler, die in mein System passen, wenn es eine Systemfrage sein sollte. Und Philippe Sanches wird halt nicht, wie prognostiziert, in ein bis zwei Jahren für 10 bis 15 Millionen verkauft werden, sondern wird jetzt im Winter oder im Sommer an den anderen Zweitligisten verliehen und startet vielleicht nicht durch. Und es kommt halt nicht zu dieser Marktwertentwicklung, die dann halt für Schalke barees Geld bedeutet. Dann muss ich eben Ben Manga auch anhören, okay, vielleicht bist du eben nicht das diamanten Auge, als das bei uns verkauft wurde und als das du dich präsentiert hast. Ich finde halt, nach vier Spieltagen schon so in die Offensive zu gehen, ein verheerendes Zeichen, weil da ja eigentlich Ben Manga gezeigt hat, wie weit es bei ihm mit Geduld ist, die er eigentlich dann nach außen predigt.
Ja, stimmt. Das ist eine nette Poarte. Und das ist interessant. Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass wir über Schalke jetzt länger reden als über Darmstadt, weil ich mir dachte, so viele Themen gibt es ja gerade gar nicht. Und doch gibt es auch so Parallelen, die nicht absolut gleich sind, aber diese schnelle Unruhe, diese Unfähigkeit, die nachvollziehbare Unfähigkeit, also es ist nicht als Vorwurf gemeint, eben Geduld zu haben. Gleichzeitig aber auch, dass man sich immer wieder implizit und manchmal auch explizit an Vereinen orientiert, die dann doch diese Geduld haben. Also Matthias, wenn du eben checkst, wie lange sind die Zweitligatrainer denn bei ihren Vereinen, dann kann ich nicht, um hinzuglauben, dass das auch damit zusammenhängt, dass dein Verein in Anführungszeichen eben gerade wieder seinen Trainer gewechselt hat. Also interessant.
Wobei man sagen muss, die Ligen hatte ich gerade nochmal mich rückversichert. Das letzte Mal, dass sie einen Trainer entlassen hatten, war 2019. Seitdem sind sie schon sehr beharrlich an ihrem Trainerpersonal geblieben. Und wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass tatsächlich auch das fast ein Lieberknecht einen Anteil an der Trennung jetzt hatte, dann ist es eben seit fünf Jahren so, dass der Verein nur sehr ungern irgendwie eine Konsequenz zieht. Es lief ja auch lange genug gut oder so, dass man zumindest nicht große Sorgen haben musste. Die Erstligasaison ging in die Hose. Da haben auch sicherlich die Entscheider über den Trainer ihren Anteil dran. Aber ich denke, das ist etwas, was Kohfeldt jetzt sicherlich auch zu pass kommt. Das hat man vorhin schon angedeutet. Er findet hier ein ruhiges Umfeld vor, gleichwohl. Eines, das schon mittlerweile sehr sensibilisiert ist, weil aus der ersten Liga abzusteigen, kann man einpreisen. Die Anweise war überhaupt nicht gut. Das macht auch was mit dem Umfeld. Wenn man quasi so als verschlechster Absteiger der Bundesliga-Historie verschrien wird, dann ist es auch etwas, was deutschlandweit das Image nicht gerade befördert. Aber jetzt gucken wir mal. Jetzt ist jeder so ein bisschen auf heißen Kohlen und hofft, dass der Umschwung kommt. Gleichwohl mit zwei wirklich wichtigen Spielen, die verletzt sind. Das wird alles andere als ein Selbstläufer. Ich glaube, das war vielen klar oder viele haben es befürchtet und jetzt scheint es tatsächlich so zu werden. Und ich hoffe, dass wir kein Bielefeld nachmachen, sondern eher Schalke, die ja letztes Jahr sich auch dann auch rausgezogen haben aus dem Strudel. Und eine personelle Verbindung gibt es tatsächlich zwischen den Ligen und den Schalken und zwar Yannick Bachmann. Er war in Darmstadt in der Jugend, fünf Jahre lang. Und ich glaube, er ist jetzt nicht so ein typischer Spieler, den man Ben Manga zuschreibt. Deshalb keine Ahnung, wie er nach Schalke gekommen ist. Er verkaufte ja was anderes als ein Spieler, der irgendwann mal für viel mehr Geld verkauft wird. Also er ist sicherlich ein Stabilisator, würde ich mal annehmen. Ich habe ihn jetzt noch nicht gesehen, in Königsblau. Aber ich glaube, er ist etwas, was den Königsblauen Anhang auch durchaus zusagt, wenn er gerne mal etwas Rustikale aufräumt.
Ja, vor allem hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass er so eine prägende Rolle einnimmt im Team. Also ich hätte eher gedacht, dass er mehr von der Bank kommt, aber er ist ja eigentlich seit Minute eins gesetzt als Zerstörer und Störenfried im Mittelfeld.
Du benenzt es völlig falsch. Holding Six. Dann ist er gleich 5 Millionen Euro teurer.
Ja, okay. Aber dann müssten wir ihn nicht Janik Bachmann, sondern Joao Bagmanio nennen oder so. Dann können wir ihn auch für 45 Millionen zum FC Bayern transferieren nächste Saison.
So schaut es nämlich aus. Aber ich glaube, man kann abschließend sagen, es sind…
Entschuldigung, Max, da komme ich noch mit einem Fun Fact um die Ecke, wo du gerade schon mir die Bühne bereitest, Dominik. Und zwar Janek Bachmann heißt offiziell Janik J. Bachmann. Und ich weiß von einem sehr guten Freund, der aus demselben Dorf stammt, wie Janik Bachmann oder zumindest aus einem benachbarten Dorf, dass der Vater glühender Eintracht-Fan ist und Janik Bachmann JJ. Bachmann nennen wollte, was beim Standesamt nicht durchging oder beim Geburtsregister. Und deshalb heißt er Janik J. Bachmann. Also JJ. Okocsa hat irgendwo auch seine Spuren bei Janik Bachmann hinterlassen. Vielleicht geht da noch was auf dem Transfermarkt.
Ich bin mal gespannt, gegen welchen Torhüter JJ. Okoccas Jahrhundertor dupliziert.
Also wenn er es tut, dann mit Grätschen, aber nicht mit Übersteigern. Aber es wird genauso spektakulär. Aber das ist nämlich genau der Punkt. Ich glaube, abschließend kann man sagen, bei beiden Teams, sowohl bei Darmstadt 98 als auch bei Schalke, lohnt es sich jetzt drauf zu blicken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bei den einen, weil sie mutigen Fußball spielen wollen, was noch nie jemand spielen wollte. Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Und sollte die Abwehr nicht stabilisiert werden, wird immer was passieren bei Darmstadt spielen. Das kann man sagen. Und bei Schalke 04 hat man eben diese viele unbekannten Spieler. Wir beachten jetzt natürlich sowieso immer nur noch auf die Innenverteidigung. Torhüter haben wir jetzt gar nicht thematisiert, aber es wird ja noch öfter um Schalke gehen in dieser Saison. Aber es gibt eben diese vielen Spieler, die wirklich das Potenzial bieten zu träumen und wo man eben dann– also da verstehe ich jeden Schalke-Fan und das ist ja auch das Schöne daran– jeder Neuzugang ist potenziell Ballon d'Or-Gewinner der Zukunft. Und erst nach 10, 15 Spielen gesteht man ihnen zu, ach nee, ach deswegen spielst du hier.
Wobei wir unseren künftigen Ballon d'Or-Gewinner ja jetzt zum Waldhof abgegeben haben in Henning-Bandricciani.
Ja, okay, gut. Aber das ist doch nur eine Laie, oder? Da kommt er doch wieder. Wird er jetzt nicht veredelt vom Waldhof? Kennt man nicht da für den Waldhof?
Man munkelt ja, dass Schalke sich nicht unbedingt wünscht, dass er zurückkommt. Aber mal schauen.
Na gut, was soll man sagen? Ihr zwei, dass die Folgen kürzer werden, das hat nicht geklappt. Aber es hat auf jeden Fall geklappt, dass wir tief bei euren Vereinen rangegangen sind. Und wir haben immer noch nicht alles besprochen. Deswegen wird der Rasenfunk immer so lang. Ich sag's euch, liebe Leute. Aber ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit. Herzlichen Dank an Matthias Kneifl. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es weitergeht bei Darmstadt. Danke dir, lieber Matthias.
Ich auch, vielen Dank.
Und herzlichen Dank an Dominik Slišković. Schön, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Und jetzt können wir es ja bis zu 44 auf jeden Fall schon mal durchziehen, also zu deinem 44.
Auftritt. Ich bitte doch darum. Vielen Dank.
Ja, danke dir auch für deine Zeit. Und ich möchte auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, danken. Zum einen für euer Feedback, dass ihr uns bitte gebt auf diese Folge unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und in allen sozialen Netzwerken eurer Art. Bitte bewertet auch gerne den Rasenfunk bei der Podcastplattform Eure Wahl. Das habe ich schon ganz lange nicht mehr gesagt. Und empfiehlt uns weiter. Dieser Ligatour-Feed ist sehr beliebt bei allen, die ihn kennen, aber ihn kennen immer noch sehr wenige. Also empfiehlt diese Folge, postet sie in entsprechenden Formen und so weiter und so fort. Und unterstützt uns auch sehr gerne finanziell. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist werbe-, payable und sponsorenfrei und wird allein von euch finanziert. Und da sind unter anderem mit dabei Max aus Oslo, Hans Kovac, Bahnchef AD, Jonathan, Kilian und nico. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club gegangen und haben uns dort finanziell unterstützt. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Bleibt gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk treu. Nächste Woche geht es hoffentlich an dieser Stelle mit der europäischen Ausgabe weiter. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund. Bis bald. Ciao. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.